two
yo people of the world it's uh so
trained I don't know it is Wednesday
though you know that song people of the
world Soul Train yeah are you just
saying that or am I actually you're my
memory no I know the song I wasn't sure
if I was even saying the words right
losers
slay Queen is that 30 seconds
I'm ready for me too
stop dissing the Nazis all the time
shofie will more or less
I'm dreaming of my next Tucker what you
know we know we know we know we know
while sucking a smoker it's all had to
say if it's practice
that bro a an edit honoring
okay
apparently of all people who we love
yeah you guys I came in this morning oh
by the way we're sponsored by gamer sup
who you know this beverage this is the
beverage
of the Super Trooper Nation
this is it right here folks love gamer
Subs
yeah you guys scared the crap out of me
this morning when I walked in
I didn't know that these guys were
planning to do an avatar walkout they
said if I don't go give Avatar a
positive review they are going to be on
strike that's right we took inspiration
from darman's crew uh we are banding
together to fight back against the
Injustice of all of this unwarranted
Avatar hate Cameron was trying to
[__] put his little Avatar tendrils
on Alfredo yeah he's trying to [__] my
dog
I know what those tendrils mean bro I
know what they mean I've seen the first
one
Pam was putting on his makeup in front
of the mirror sat down and his tail was
sticking out and the tail looked like it
needed to be there this whole time yeah
I feel so natural with the tail I need a
tail now I think you need it I just want
to say you guys look like idiots
um
you guys look so stupid and he should be
you're so ashamed of yourself you're
stupid with your beige skin
dude Zach
L plus you're white Zach Zach was just
looking as in the mirror just hating
just just straight up jealous well he's
right well you guys look like idiots
whole life hold on hold on hold on I've
noticed that Zach and Olivia are on
they're not participating yeah they look
dumb you're right I am a uh unsatisfied
moviegoer
you both saw it and did not like no I
didn't see it Olivia saw it I refuse I
didn't I didn't hate it I just am not a
huge whale girl she ran out of a whale
phobia it was just it was time to go as
soon as that thing possibly could have
come out of the wall it's a two [__]
it's a two-coon you didn't even say bye
I'm like what where's Olivia I did what
happened the 3D whale was too it was too
big for you it was too big you have what
did they call that lassophobia or
something fear of ocean and depths and
monsters whales just big whales the
ocean doesn't scare you
eat no not as much as big whale what
about like giant squids and [__] like
that not as much as big ones giant
sharks it's uh the amount of mass that a
blue whale has it's too much for
anything but they're nice isn't that
does that help you at all it could be
nice it could smile open its mouth okay
I'm inside of it already I don't think
anyone's ever been here
oh come on get that off the screen you
guys this is such a sweet moment
you know what I was just thinking I saw
a b in his little loincloth stand up and
show that I was like man there ain't no
way they're giant Avatar dick ain't
flopping around look at that that's it
just a little loincloth was that it's a
fairly long loincloth to be yeah and I
know why exactly
could hang up you could hang from a tree
on that thing I just cut a hole in my
suit second tail yeah the other tail so
thank God I have this lung cloth yeah I
didn't even know that there was like
Marine avatars in two that is so stupid
you guys
look how dumb this looks excuse me it
looks like [__] dude it looks so dumb oh
my God that guy look [__] cool dude
what the [__] this is good this is good
yeah oh it's not bad guys Dan he looks
like a Paul Giamatti and Big Fat Liar
that's right the God one of the greatest
actors of all time Harry is wearing
Oakleys bruh dumb why would you become
an avatar to wear Oakleys I will say
they're called sunglasses the Oakleys
are kind of hype as [__] I will give you
that thank you uh everything else is
just stupid yeah so anyway y'all are
standing hard in opposition of me and
Gabe who's going to be very disappointed
in you guys
this is what you guys look like by the
way
this is how cool you guys look right now
oh he's got [__] drip that's how I
looked the first time I got the wrong
makeup I didn't know Sam got a different
type here I'll show you my it's it's
it's nothing was racist about it yeah it
looks a little racist I sent a picture
of it
it's kind of funny though but yeah it's
a little [__] up
I don't know why because it's blue right
but it's almost it's very offensive it
is yeah it's very offensive Amy's having
a rough day shame on you actually I'm
actually regret sending this already
he's feeling a little blue today
thank you Zach all right Zach
oh yeah this is actually the funniest
thing that happened this morning
Sam took a Teddy fresh meeting and she
was already in costume we blurred out
the other employees but she sent us a
screenshot of her on the zoom call
looking you know I had a similar
experience because we did Gekko on
Monday and my face was all green and I
kept it on because I wanted to show
Theodore and you know
it's hard to explain in fact I don't
even try I go
I just go
sometimes it is what it is
I said just a weird day at work you guys
I don't know what else to say
yeah so
um you guys scared the crap out of me
you guys want to roll the video you took
of me walking in
oh what the
[__] this is crazy
Legos
yeah I thought I was like tripping acid
or something
okay welcome to Pandora
you got it we're going this afternoon on
the sixth time you're not an avatar
your [__] trash piece of movie so you
are all the Jesus Jesus Christ so y'all
are the the ones that love avatars
all right man
yeah
that was
just like
one of the most shocking things I've
ever seen in terms of just trying to con
compute
I was weird man but good job you guys
you definitely got me thank you yeah we
said when you walk in we're all gonna
hiss like the avatars and everyone was
quiet and Lena goes
wait why did y'all I did a good hissy
they did a good one
none of us we bailed on the plane but
I'm proud of you for keeping with it
good for you yeah we talked about that
and then nobody else did it so Ethan
walked in I'm just like to him but
that's okay I was looking at Lena and I
was like dude what is her deal
no I'm just kidding I didn't even know
this by the way thank you Bella Simmons
who's graciously gifted 70. my goodness
70. memberships
I don't see the option on iOS mobile to
buy Subs anyone
um
I have no idea
I know it matters on where you live and
what device you're on I don't know how
yeah I don't think that it's uh on iOS
probably because YouTube's like I'm not
giving
the cut definitely 30 right exactly
um but if you uh sign up on another
device it will you'll you'll get the
benefits of it
on your device you just can't um
you can't actually sign up on your
iPhone yeah and you can subscribe from
Safari and stuff like that too yeah
there you go and members had uh feasted
yesterday because we had a wonderful
members only show yesterday where we
reacted to Old H3 H3 videos and gave you
a little BTS there so everyone's having
fun
um
so there was that so thank you guys we
actually have so much to talk about
today so many great things and sad
things as you guys can see where we're
starting a light but I did lose brutally
my lawsuit to Ryan Cavanaugh I am now
you're bankrupt right I'm in shambles
actually there's truth to that there is
truth to that we did lose emotion
and then recover wrote some like insane
puff or I'm speculating that it was
cathcock because nobody else cares about
him we have reason to believe I'm angry
met our boy
but the headline's awesome dude it's so
good he goes Brian Kavanaugh wins slap
motion Ethan Klein loses what damages
potentially in the Millions
we'll get to that look at this [__]
guy dude thank you you can almost hear
[Music]
Brad
nailing his wife background
you know what I mean yeah almost no I do
know what you mean
yeah we love you Kev you're a good man
foreign
yes so we'll get to that actually but
before that I want to give a shout out
to my wonderful wife who has put
together a wonderful collection here
Teddy fresh coming out tomorrow 10 a.m
new drop this denim jacket
wrong way this denim jacket
we're cool
like radioactive buttons they're awesome
and then underneath this shirt I love
this shirt
jack it off
moth experience Love at First Cent did
you guys know that
I do know that's a nice Graphics it's a
scientifically accurate shirt it is we
got it out of an animal facts book
really
worked around that
um
apparently he's the author
uh
his name was uh
uh uh
well [__] I can't remember what's the
guy's name from Wikipedia our boy
throws drost
what is it roast
Pros the roast oh yeah throws throws
yeah written by throw
the length for a second you'd think that
somebody who I was working intimately
with and paying remember who he was joke
parody parody not real
yeah he's not admissible here's a little
bit of a preview I know ela's been super
hyped about this one we got this nice uh
sweater also we developed this custom
pin
super cool
this is some kind of floral set
you love to see it oh that one's cool
you love to see it this we worked with
the artists
really cool Artist Artist
well let's turn it at like like Tyson
for a second
here's the jacket I was wearing
nice little Polo you know what it is
rhinestones on the collar you know what
it is
cherubs you know what it is this is the
one I'm wearing okay High fashion
bleached that's nice whoa I want that
one yeah whoa dude what that frick
yo this is a dress
shirt dress shirt
oversized dress shirt
is it oversized I guess maybe or maybe
she's got a large size
lots of cute fits for the ladies ELO's
was uh emphasizing the ladies will Feast
this shirt is my fave I don't date
crypto Bros that's it that's the shirt
it's an important message I think yeah
and I think uh it's important to put
that out there this is wonderful set
there for the ladies this tattoo oh I
mean the socks that was like the focal
point and then you know what it is you
know what it is you know what it is
there it is thank you guys for watching
tomorrow at 10 am
tomorrow being Thursday
all right
dude
I guess let me just talk about the Cav
cab thing right at the top because
people are going to be wondering
so let's see let's read this article
that kavcav put out
yeah did we ever cover the article that
we are first of all when I say Cav Kev
put out let me just emphasize that this
is all speculation
I don't know if Cav
was involved in uh producing this
article I do know that the amount of
people who would care about producing
this article is about one thank you
so you can you can make your own
deductions from that
did we ever talk about that one hit
website
it was oh I don't think we actually did
it was like his response to uh does Ryan
Kavanaugh look like Harvey Weinstein
yeah and again speculation
are you talking about Ethan should be
banned or whatever oh yeah yeah yeah
it's actually cited in the article oh no
way 100 all right so here's what
happened okay
this is on the defamation case this is
the one where he's suing me
for reading a Variety article right
now we filed anti-slap which is
basically
uh means that you can't when you are
suing somebody for defaming a public
figure
California has this mechanism called the
anti-slap which is to prevent people
from suppressing Free Speech who are you
know have the money and tools to
litigate you into the ground
that's a great thing
we use it a lot because of the nature of
how we get sued for [__] and what I do
this time it was denied by the judge
the judge is a Crusty old [__] with
peace and love
he has of all the anti-slaps only ever
admitted one in his whole career the
average in California is 90 success whoa
this crusty old [__]
just has never granted an anti-slap only
one time in his whole career huh and so
um but but here's the thing the ant the
loss on the anti-slap motion doesn't
mean anything because they'll tell you
this
it just means it goes back to the
beginning right but this is like just
you're trying to get it dismissed on
face or you're trying to get dismissed
on just like this is [__]
like the the Matt Haas one we never went
the anti-slap and we've we fought that
[__] all the way through so it's
sending it back to that but
even before that
we're going to appeal this
we've already filed the paperwork to a
higher court or to appeal the anti-slap
yeah oh so that's not even over no you
could still win this anti-slot I think
that we have like a extremely high
chance of winning the anti-stop because
that judge is a is a Crusty old [__] as
I've noted this is very confusing to me
because I I read this article and
apparently you've lost and you owe Ryan
Kavanaugh several billion dollars
that's what it sounds like you're a
loser yeah uh but do I believe you or do
I believe very real person David David
Thomas David Tom Thomas illustrious uh
author of
Tech times the prestigious uh Tech times
actually I haven't read this yet but I'm
looking forward to it
but um
yeah so what happens when we appeal as
it goes to a higher Court the court of
appeals which is like a big deal right
if he loses on this stage it's going to
be much worse for him it's a much bigger
deal in terms of legal precedent
interesting
and it goes before three judges and
these judges are going to know the rules
on the law around anti-slap this judge
did not and this is going to be in my
opinion an easy dub on appeal and it's
going to actually be even worse for Kev
Kev in that case
so it's far from over you know what I
mean angry he should be scared that this
is getting tossed up to a higher
a higher uh
you know
higher Court one step closer to a
televised trial
uh that's like a jury trial that's
that's that ain't happening that would
be a dream
I want to understand I want you on the
stand in shorts and slides yeah in the
same in the same room as Ryan Kavanaugh
dropped yeah well well the appeals
you're like dude
Harvey Weinstein right am I right ladies
and gentlemen I'll represent myself
ladies and gentlemen of the courtroom
here's a picture of Harvey Weinstein oh
wait sorry Ryan Cavanaugh wait this is
oh [__] that is Brian Cavanaugh is a
force of nature he sure is
yeah but actually so the appeal isn't
even going to be heard for like a year
to a year and a half so the timeline on
this [__] is like snail is moving at a
snail speed which is why
I didn't even talk about it it's not
really a big deal I'm not worried
at all
I mean as far as now the only one who
owes money is Ryan Kavanaugh owes me
like over sixty thousand dollars and
that one is done done they didn't even
appeal it they knew it was such a
[__] loss and Hell
get [__] so
yeah so let's read the article let's see
what this puff uh this this stink piece
Ryan Cavanaugh went slap motion Ethan
Klein loses with damages potentially in
the Millions
[Music]
yeah the slap doesn't say anything about
damages it's just about if it can get
thrown out on that's what like the
second I saw this article because it got
posted on the subreddit or something
just from the headline alone I was like
what is this because like that that's
not what that means at all and then
another read on it becomes very clear
what's going on here
let's see in a man in the matter of
Kavanaugh verse Klein wherein why are
you writing that why are you writing
like that bro wherein Ryan Kavanaugh has
incline and Asia he's like doing uh
keyword stuffing yeah that's yeah
why does it lie and his Affiliates what
Affiliates what are you even talking
about
or what could be many millions of
dollars many
a key motion was ruled in favor of
Kavanaugh La Superior Court
climb brought before the court what is
referred to as anti-slap Motion in cases
like these are usually granted that's my
point right slap stands for strategic
lawsuit against public participation
California has one of the strongest
anti-slap stances with over 90 percent
being granted Will Smith and again
this this across the old [__]
has only granted one
in his whole career whereas the average
is 90 success you do the math on that
yeah
but again I'm not I'm not worried at all
my whatever my Affiliates right does
Ryan Kavanaugh look like Harvey
Weinstein no throwstand uh oh no way
they mentioned my Affiliates yes they do
Klein evidently has two or more
Wikipedia editors
if this is journalism this has to be
some level of libel
evidently what's the evidence the
evidence is that they were mean to Ryan
Cavanaugh on Wikipedia no but like must
be connected this this is why I was
saying very obvious that Ryan basically
wrote this article because who like
who's in the weeds like that about
thrust he's the only one beside our
audience
Pokey 35 we don't even ever talk about
right
that's like real deep cut they also say
that they both spend 90 of their time
destroying uh Ryan's Wikipedia article
who has 90 of their time to be on
Wikipedia you know what I mean
right let's get well let's see as Ken
scene from a simple Wiki history search
these individuals spend 90 of their time
dude that that is such an insane State
destroying Klein's enemy does yours
Wikipedia page profiles oh so actively
destroying all enemies of the show while
making positive changes to Klein and
hd's profile the only
I'll say this the only enemies pages I
have destroyed was on Wiki feed
and I'm not hiding but from the truth
yeah
very open about that
H3 equals free law school from David
Whispers that's right you're all ready
to represent
your friends and family in court
you can view their activity logs on
Wikipedia and clearly see that a
majority of their activity over the past
year has been spent on making defamatory
edits to Kavanaugh's Wikipedia page and
propping up H3 in the clients
dude he's he's demented
I love still always going back to how
when this all started Ryan Kavanaugh was
like your toy podcast you better you
better be careful because you're messing
with real things little boy and now he's
just like obsessed with thrust
he's like in so deep yeah yeah like I
don't even think about him I haven't
thought about kavakov in like months
right yeah and he's obsessed with thrust
messaging people on a Shrek form talking
about I finally found you
whenever this is finally over in like
another year or two like we we have to
like spend a whole episode just doing
like kind of a summation of the whole
Saga because there's so many funny
details like that that I forgot the
Shrek thing is oh good Shrek forums
finally around you
again all speculation of course but who
else is looking for thrust on a Shrek
form well
too much wine sorry
uh let's see according to reporters
committee for Freedom Express and ruling
on the motion to strike okay so you're
giving me uh legal lessons now
the ruling is significant that has
almost the same effect as a complete
case ruling you idiot
what
that is insanely stupid
idiot it has the same ruling
as a complete case ruling
yeah that's like the first literally
it's like what this isn't accurate at
all
holy [__] Klein did in fact uh knowingly
spread what happened
only spread false misleading statements
with the intent to damage or harm
Kavanaugh the ramifications of the
clients actually was Amplified by the
fact that Klein published
the damaging statements to his large
following on YouTube
he published false statements to
Millions
you this is just kavkav rage writing
also it's not written well we know kept
Ryan Cavanaugh is not very literate
he then encourages I think it's I think
it's the alcohol that's the problem I
think when he's sober he's probably
perfect do you think he shakes when he's
sober Oh Yeah from the alcohol
withdrawal too much wine sorry
he then encourages those people to
spread the false and misleading
statements okay you better watch what
you say Bud because that's the one that
you lost you tried to sue me saying that
I asked people to for spread that [__]
and you lost and you had to pay my
attorney's fees
whoever's riding this you're a loser
whoever wrote this
I only ever asked people to write a fair
and honest review of trailer the app
do you understand that bro whoever wrote
this
under tort laws that he he is sued me
for tortious interference and loss each
and every time it was republished a
state of further damage occurred what
are you talking about you already lost
that lawsuit
oh he goes leading to potentially one of
the most massive damn defamation damages
cases ever
number one baby number one podcast in
the world this could possibly record
dude this could possibly become one of
the most landmark cases of its type
since the Hulk Hogan case Hulk Hogan was
awarded 140 million in Damages
wow
that's crazy
you already lost that lawsuit though
whoever wrote this
yeah this is just the Kavanaugh who on
here comes the puff piece
unfortunately as Ryan Kavanaugh is a
business person one of the factor lar
one of the factors large institutions
Banks and companies asked is what's
called reputational risk Kavanaugh whom
has brokered over 2 billion deals okay
dude time to stop living in the past bro
you already bankrupted that [__] let's
move on dude
where is uh where's your movie studio
now
some of the largest entertainment
transactions could suffer extreme
significant damages caused by Klein's
toy podcast
uh certain laws exist blah blah
notably for this lawsuit the judge found
the final ruling uh also then he starts
talking about how apparently
I'm a bully
it's awesome dude
this is awesome talking about how I get
strikes on YouTube
oh then he cites this website
which is totally not written by the same
person
Kevin has he's called the ban of Ethan
Klein it's an awesome dude look at this
[__] is this just like a WordPress
preset what is this
um probably yeah it seems like a very
cheaply I I if this is pure speculation
but I'm thinking
Ryan had been hitting the sauce one
evening and was doing his daily check-in
on uh does he look like Harvey Weinstein
he was like I should do this too and
went on Fiverr or some [__] and you know
is probably and I I you know you read
through it there's a lot of like
grammar mistakes that are very telling
that this was an extremely it looks like
a scam website bro yeah you're trying to
Hard Sell me on ban Ethan so you got to
check out the latest signatures on the
website well before we do that I do want
to emphasize that if you type Ryan
Kavanaugh because I I think I get what
he's trying to do
but if you scroll down actually the
second result here
is does Ryan Kevin look like carving YC
now if you type his name into Google
and that's important to do
search and then come click this website
which is number two
he owes me you'll find that he owes me
almost 61 000
and spend some time brushing up on this
just spend some time on the website
scrolling reading
maybe we have a game at the bottom it'd
be nice to participate in that watch
some videos you know what I mean
and uh just to just to refresh because
frankly
it's I don't want him to be confused for
Harvey that's just not fair to him it's
not fair it's disgusting that people
make that comparison and I I'm here to
basically
um
I want to clear his name this man is not
Harvey Weinstein
despite looking just like him and a lot
of Life similarities matching up too
actually interestingly
so there's that so let's check out let's
check out his website or whoever's
website
the ban of Ethan Klein prevent all types
of abuse the vanity the client sign the
petition yes where's this petition going
homophobia and racism see violations
wait what's a what what is a violation
of like what's the violation xenophobia
and harassment I love this this is great
this is bad child abuse exploitation
what the [__] did I do
wait what
hate speech you know what we're Trisha's
photo
wait I'm really curious what's that
child endangered homophobe and racism I
I'll admit to that xenophobia I guess
I'll admit to that in the K-pop plays
harassment I don't know if I'll
let's see what's child exploitation oh
it just goes to the top of the page it
doesn't do anything
yeah Kev if you're TR if you now Cav cab
if you're involved in this website
whoever's involved in this website let's
say that whoever it may be
you're gonna have to do better I mean I
want to see the violations it just takes
me to the top of the page
I think it might be broken at least have
the [__] also we might be we might be
unintentionally uh ddosing it right now
uh with all of our fans flooding to it
so well I'm trying to help get the
message out we gotta ban Ethan Klein
yeah and yeah no that's true and I want
to sign the petition how do I see the
petition signatures go to the bottom oh
the bottom of the page
all right yep Daniel Keem Buffalo no
shot bro that's hilarious
wait these are all from today you guys
did this this is on this is people
coming oh this people are fast yeah dude
Daniel game that's awesome okay your
name is putting any sensitive
information into this website it's a
Workforce website this [__] gets easily
leaked yeah that's a good call yeah
don't put anything sensitive in there
I'm drunk
Cap's drug dealer oh my God
all the way over in Afghanistan pay your
Nanny Kevin drug dealer I don't know
anything about that
this is a badly designed website
thrustwicky mud Vladimir Putin
so this is interesting
I can't even scroll to the next page
damn
it most likely grabs your ip2 WordPress
likes to do that so don't even do goofy
ones to be honest
oh [__] this one's age restricted
jobless ugly white
Ethan is seriously Disturbed and
obsessed with race
I have not seen this video but uh for
sure I don't know that I'm obsessed with
race but you're allowed to have your
thesis there
for sure
um
oh [__] the downfall of H3 even like one
of these is awesome
hahaha
it's just a clip of a bunch of hate
videos
great man I'm glad you put on this video
again
twice
so that one he put three times that
video I think it's compelling stuff yeah
no that's a solid the band of Ethan
klein.com is a global petition page that
focuses on the ban of Ethan Klein online
harassment cyber bullying gay bashing
an abusive speech against minorities
only a few of the many reasons to ban
won't bless them all I mean right it
does sound pretty bad there's a notable
they missed a really important one um he
didn't mention the fact that you're fat
which is really the biggest my wife is
ugly and that is very ugly that's the
those are the biggest defenses yeah if
you mentioned that this thing would be
stacked with signatures I don't know
where the signatures go or for who they
are yeah but they're there and do
individuals and groups from all over the
world may start campaigns rally support
and collaborate to get Ethan banned from
social media this is nice it's a
worldwide movement
the fan of Ethan klein.com allows you to
sign several online petitions oh those
are the okay there seem to only be one
but to support the vanity incline by
harnessing the collective effort of the
online community we can evoke change and
induce the social networks
that's awesome
the social networks
the Ethan Klein band is a non-profit
movement Burrows this is a non-profit
they're doing it for the Love of the
Game baby I mean you're taking donations
what does that mean
the Ryan Kavanaugh fund aka the band
Ethan Klein
.com movement
the website was registered on
uh February February 21. was that line
up with anything interesting love
I'm not sure I'm trying to find out more
information about the website than the
hosting and stuff we probably launched
our website around that time maybe this
was a direct Tit for Tat that he tried
to do could be yeah smart or whoever
made this website let's be clear we
don't know that Ryan is behind this yeah
we don't although
if you consider the amount of people who
would make this website
there's really only one
even keemstar is not dumb enough to make
this [__]
like keemstar is not that dumb actually
it's not that bad and and I'm not trying
to compliment him by saying that he is
extraordinarily dumb very very 16 is the
age of consent but Ryan Kavanaugh is
like Boomer dumb this man
he's like drive drunk and hit a police
car dumb
[Music]
um
he's I want to have an appropriate
relationship with a 14 year old Natalie
Portman dumb
if you are harassed by Ethan Klein you
can sign our online petition for the ban
for support hotlines and help oh God we
need a Ethan Klein harassment hotline
please click here it doesn't work
not clickable
we hope to supply useful tool for
signing an online petition against you
think Clinton has negative influence on
children and young people what the [__]
did I do
why you gotta invoke children
the vanity inclined was established in
response to an increase in online abuse
and harassment of children and young
people what the [__]
platforms dedicated raise awareness and
Advocate positive change yet yada yada
then he just links a bunch of hate
videos
[Music]
Ian Slater hey Ian come on don't put
your name down there
Ryan Kavanaugh is a stupid punk ass
[__]
that was not you for the record right
and
my hands are tied you're busy you're
literally busy watching the show
he's a busy guy although we don't see
his tail
you just saying let's see the tail in
hands up tail up
yeah you're good it looks clean he's
clean lick my balls I Ethan saggy tits
McGee where's my mom I'm lost rhinos
Ethan 61k
so you know this is cool this is cool I
appreciate the
the thing is though this website is
really compelling in that
it's very factual
so cool this one's very factual so much
so that this guy's suing me for
defamation and they
nothing on this website even
that I wrote here was even challenged
is that interesting
this website's been vetted
tested
and that's all I'll say about it thank
you yeah so you know we haven't talked
about Ryan cabcap in a while so it's
nice to just touch in and say hello to
this beautiful mug before we move on I
did want to just mention one last thing
that um last night when I found this I
looked up the author of that article yes
and wouldn't you know it uh I very
quickly discovered that he is a PR
writer who other work on that same
website seems to mostly consist of puff
pieces for like medium level employees
of random tech companies almost like
they're maybe trying to boost up their
resume and online presence a little bit
not saying it's not genuine but it is
interesting that he's the author same
author he's not a journalist for example
it seemed I I don't want to question his
credibility necessarily he's a freelance
writer but he does seem like a total
[__] hack who loser who does Puff
pieces for money why does it lie that
says so I'm saying that's what I'm
saying well this is him what's muckrack
is that I guess it's a website where
it's it's
four PR stuff like muckrack your new
standard in public relations software
easily search for journalist modern news
build reports so he has a profile on
here
um which kind of means that
I don't know if he is even a real person
it might just be a fake person and this
is like an AI written article from a
bunch of info that Ryan provided to this
company that could be more expensive
than just hiring some maybe dude in
India to write it yeah which is what I
think he did it could be that too and
and either way I'm a little suspicious
of if uh Dave Thomas the Wendy's guy is
actually this
involved in yo I've had Wendy's in a
minute though uh-oh did I just trigger
something in you when's the last time
you had Wendy's though 15 years ago Sam
I see you smiling back there what do you
have to say I love Wendy's dude I've had
Wendy's in such a long time all the time
you guys yeah there's one semi-close
it's kind of a drive you guys eat good
you and Ian I'm jealous I miss being
young yo you're good
eat good boy should we get Wendy's have
you seen those French toast sticks I'm
gonna regret it so much French toast
yeah don't come on you're on a journey
don't you want to mail this Dome I'm on
a journey to Wendy's
Wendy's next
Wendy Williams I don't trust Wendy's
they got Square hamburgers
what are they up to
well making Square hamburgers why do
they feel like they need to do that
what's up what's in those burgers
doesn't beef jerky I don't trust like
that okay you don't even eat meat Dan so
I'll talk [__] on the Square on the
Square Patty
yeah so um
he's actually a prolific writer I resent
what you said David Thompson has written
for Wiley Online Library Tech times
K-pop Stars Helio oh that's why he's
after you yakaima Herald Republic
Times columnist nature world news
headlines in Global News
Latin post and more
wait
this guy just posted what the [__] he
posted three articles
in the last hour
yeah and look like how's that before the
ones from last night that I was Finding
were the same kind of thing that that
top one
sasi Kumar Raju expertise in master data
management boosts organ like this is
like
an old company in the last hour there's
been one two three four five six
articles by this guy I'm telling you I
think it might be a computer six
articles in an hour I smell a Pulitzer
Prize winner right here Peabody
a Peabody and investigating why is
kavcap and I'm speculating that it's him
he's so dumb he literally is so
incompetent yeah no he can't even put
together like a hit website of course
Everything You Touch turns his [__] bro
you literally would be a [__] you
would be a valet no offense to the valet
people I've done a great job what's they
make good tips
yeah
if he wasn't a total nepo baby uh Ron
Kavanaugh yeah
um it would be he'd be like the dude to
uncut gems just hustle to hustle that's
too good for him no his energy he gives
me assistant manager at a restaurant
thank you he gives me he gives me like
the the the evening shift that none of
the other managers want to take maybe we
can just say he he'd be a security guard
or a cop so that because we don't like
them already thank you I don't think
he's here hard lives matter dude we
respect security guards in this office I
don't think he's tough
the security guards are dope
but like do you see how incompetent you
are bro it's insane like it's not that
hard to put together a website
confidently you have money why would you
do it in such a stupid cheap way where
you got a [__]
AI author who's writing eight articles
an hour
what are you doing dude
understanding think about it dude
dude understanding damages and personal
injury cases an app to earn in the gig
economy three digital platforms to
become a millionaire these are all in
the past hour the greedy machines nft on
binance
the best tools for online trading on
Linux fast dude he's so good eight all
in the last hour he's pumping these out
yeah I think it's either an AI thing or
that's just a moniker that like like you
said you know a bunch of people in the
Philippines are all
writing these articles and then they
just publish it under Dave Thomas but
what's the advantage because if you go
here he's clearly not real like it's so
blatantly because I think it's all just
like SEO [__] like like most of those
articles are just again like some middle
manager at a tech company that is
looking for a new job and he wants when
people Google his name some article to
come up that seems complementary of him
yeah I guess
oh I want to thank um what does this
mean Nick Clark thank you for the Dono
so much he said please drop the Suki
diss track what does that mean
s that was the winner of the cat
competition yeah definitely Nick
yeah [__] yeah
did you do that and then we should do uh
our ads because we're already about 10
minutes past the time anyway what did
you what's who's how did you find this
love James who's James Rogers I think
it's like a default website or a page
from the dude how do the template
oh what the [__] it has a watermark on
it James Rogers volunteer Lauren ipsum
oh yeah that's just like the deeper yeah
and here's the privacy policy on the
website why are you so stupid bro oh wow
oh here's the privacy policy let's see
hey bro you ever heard of this rankings
it's funny because when you store
user.data like that in that poll or that
uh what's it called when people send in
their information like that adds like a
bunch of [__] like legally this website
is not up to date to like gdpr so they
would could get sued for this like in in
Europe Mission oh this does not follow
any gdpr uh guidelines
you should copy paste this they for sure
just copy pasted it from a website like
I wonder where they got it so you in
WordPress there's these templates that
you just click one click and you get all
these I see yeah
awesome
all right drop that song yeah let's hear
it let's let's party hey bro it serves
my arch nemesis James Rogers
Ryan Cavanaugh the founder of I'm gonna
need all the Navi on the dance floor
right now please all the navi please
stand up and did you also seriously we
had a nanny and he got sued by that
Nanny because he didn't pay her and he
also tried to frame one of his employees
of sexual harassment so he wouldn't have
to pay a severance allegedly
[Music]
mine I ain't even gonna say that leasing
all these haters cause I always get the
payback hey bro
do me a favor real quick dude you guys
look scary
someone should get close to the camera
and smile it looks so creepy it's not
you Dan because you have a beard It's
gotta be like Lena yeah let's see your
mouth two pictures right in front oh my
god get close to the camera
yeah it looks really creepy yeah
[__]
is
yes Ryan Cavanaugh my friend
yeah thank you to whoa mindful Rochester
thank you bro
save Echo VR whatever that means I don't
know what that means
save Echo VR there it is
also shout out to um
I don't know now it's not James Rogers
who who wrote that article Dave Thomas
yeah so he wrote a thousand thirteen
articles so he's a prolific writer
and just so knowledgeable about
so much everything yeah it's got a lot
of knowledge
thank you to gamer Subs by the way
I love me some gamer Subs man
this get this product has changed
the way that I experience my day
I drink it every day here on the show
it's a tasty sugar-free drink with
caffeine it hydrates me it keeps me
energized and I'm not putting on any
calories
tastes great
this I always hit the black cherry
flavor
that's the one I love
if you drink sugary drinks you got to
get off that and get on this get off you
will literally you're gonna lose weight
also it's super hydrating
um
it won't even break it won't break a
fast or take you out of case ptosis uh
for all my
elk meat lovers
you don't even have to think about it
dude they also have caffeine free
flavors if you don't want to
get yeah if you just want to taste your
drink
yeah yeah the flavors you guys like I'm
all about that blue res
coincidence that you're an avatar
um it is a little bit of a coincidence
but
you know what they say
what do they say there's no such thing
as a coincidence
true true what do you guys drink
um
raspberry lemonade I don't know if I
tried that one but the black cherry Just
Hits hard for me every time with the uh
mom milk what is it mommy milk titty
milk titty milk yeah yeah
I'm caffeine free so I love the caffeine
free one which flavor super good it's
like a I think it's there's a blue
raspberry caffeine free I think yeah I
think all the flavors flavor it is or
most of them come in caffeine free as
well do you not drink caffeine Sam no
really
been caffeine free for a year
wow and and why why is why did you make
that change if I may ask I wanted to see
if it would help my anxiety and I think
that it has yeah a lot so I guess that
makes sense because it's like a
stimulant yeah
I think they say yuck yeah so good good
night good for you
it's time to make a change
this song always goes into bad territory
so I'm gonna stop there
yo Sam said she's ordering Wendy's okay
hold on yes I do want let's rap rap
about that so anyway go to gamersup.gg
H3 to get your free sample packs yes 24
hours
freeze so true
Gamers
gamersupps.gg H3 it's in the description
all you have to do is add it to the cart
hit checkout enter your mailing address
and enter your email address
you don't even have to add your credit
card or anything
you'll be charged zero dollars and you
will get the samples right to your
freaking door that's how confident they
are
and if you missed the 24 hour window you
can always use code H3 for 10 off
anything on the website guys free put in
your address that's it
gamersupps.gg H3 thank you thank you
peace and love yes yes yes we love game
or Subs
we love gamer Subs yo what the frick get
the hell now
hell no so can avatars talk to like
can they talk to the animals yes how do
they talk to the animals they learn from
their language
how do they talk to the world you got to
watch it to find out they connect with
their
their thingy no you don't give him info
he's gotta well I'm not watching it not
even a spoiler I want to know you seem
curious it is a spoiler no I don't know
how stupid it is is it like a telepathic
connection or do they go
they don't speak whale to the whale the
whale is able to understand their
language stupid
you know what it is it's it's like a
it's like a Han and chewy situation like
they both understand each other but
neither of them speak each other's
language okay but the Han and Chewie at
least is like self-aware this doesn't
sound self-aware to me it's like
suddenly in the movie he can't
understand the whale and then in the
very next scene he's talking to the
whale
so that kind of took me out of it a
little bit everything else was perfect
10 out of 10 or 9 out of 10. this is all
the sides that Wendy has oatmeal bar
seasoned potatoes
I was a sausage biscuit aside and what
world is that aside
the world of fast food in Canada
can I get inside of a sausage biscuit
please
sir so you were you're hyping up the the
French toast sticks
yeah those look good
I have not been to Wendy's in so long
dude they really got to pay us for this
[__] so many people are going to get
Wendy's right now
oh here we go fries and sides this is
what I'm after wait they have garlic
fries yeah dude they've got garlic fries
with cheese and beef jerky they have
they have baked potatoes that's what I
get every time really loaded baked
potato that's kind of wild so good
what's that food baked potato I would
never even think to order that from a
do you how do you eat it like just with
a spoon your mouth with a fork I eat the
whole skin and everything the skin I
clean that little container and do they
fry the skin so it's like crunchy good
it's just a potato they got a ham
fingers in their chili
extra flavor and that's right they
didn't wasn't that fake that that was
proven to be fake was it I think so
actually I think so I don't think a
fingers these fingers I think somebody
put it in there and chili
dude I'm just a Wikipedia article about
this dude a scam artist yeah Wendy's
needs to pay me wait hold on stick your
finger prosecutors portrayed
Ayala as a scam artist with a pension
for filing lawsuits one of the creditors
test indicate that the finger had not
been cooked in the chili oh wow
no she faked in the news was it a real
finger though
this this sucked their finger in there I
think it was a real finger that this
psycho brought
where'd they get the finger that's like
a this is like a Lebowski situation
I'll get you toe dude I got places no
fair girlfriend cut off her tongue they
got the uh the lady who put it in the
chili she got it from her husband's
co-worker who lost it in an industrial
accident and she thought she's like
[Music]
and poor when Wendy's really got defamed
because y'all were talking about how
there was a toe in their [__] chilly
this woman got a spare finger
and she says the best thing to do with
this
is to put it in my [__] chili
it's crazy bro
apparently if you go to jail for that
that's a good question you'd think that
definitely seems like a crime led to a
felony charge of attempted grand larceny
against her to which she pled guilty
dude that's awesome nine years in prison
she's released now after four years yeah
served four is she allowed to go to
Wendy's or not anymore probably not
allowed in Wendy's dear Claire probably
still clear dude I I don't know what to
get I guess I want to get a classic here
cam just ordered a
medium French frying vanilla Frosty
that's a good Porter
yeah I'm just gonna I'm gonna try out
those garlic fries sounded interesting
okay so here at Sam's mine's gonna be a
little custom okay
why do these look like this bro why are
they why are they making this this is
that looks good
oh that I mean
I'd eat that
there you go that's why they make it
it's like a meat Mountain it's like why
did you do that
some people are into it man some people
love them what the [__] is this Italian
Mozzarella cheeseburger triple there's
four [__] knobs in there yo that
looks dank as fast
someone has gotten dried up it has like
a disc of mozzarella cheese that's fried
come on what's the other oh this is a
burger three burger patties yo can you
get me that lettuce wrap
you want that in the lettuce wraps
really okay sure you want this in a
lettuce wrap dude that's like a dream
right there yeah can I get a uh deep
fried mozzarella Patty three burger
patties ten cheeses that kind of is but
I don't want any carbs I want it to be
healthy and lettuce yes and play lettuce
please yes
the bun that's the killer here yeah
you'd be surprised actually though how
much calories you cut by not eating a
bun I'm telling you brother I mean
you're right but in that case
I'm gonna guess that it's a relatively
small percentage of this yeah that's not
gonna save you
pretzel bun oh God so maybe I'll get the
let's get the um
what's the howdy scale that's [__]
big bacon classic double
this is a this is a bad idea
[Music]
don't get me that don't give me that
don't give me that
you just get me a Dave's single
all right you got it great choice just a
classic actually no [__] come on man get
it together I'm battling with myself you
understand I'm sorry Dave are you
worried about like the the calories yes
just get like one of the little baby
ones no Ethan you'll be fine if you get
a lettuce wrapped get the I always get a
lettuce wrap too yeah no I won't eat the
bread well no this is just gonna be my
meal you know I'm just going to eat
light later I'm sorry Dave
so get me the get me the wind the Dave's
[__] classic okay Dave and then also
get me the Baconator fries because I
hate my [__] self
it was like a dude okay you want a
finger in your chili or uh and if
there's an option for note right
I can get you a tooth and a milkshake
best I can do crispy chicken BLT biggie
that sounds kind of fire okay just I
gotta wrap this up
you guys always get the combos I always
go for the combos
just me
I always get the combo I think they have
the best fries their fries are so good
not always
have your finger over that button to
disagree with Sam no matter what she
said because that was so fast oh [__]
calories
Desi Ray says I did a photo shoot for a
local art magazine and I was wearing my
Elon shirt they loved it oh that's
awesome oh cool thank you for the Dunham
by the way put that on the company card
obviously Sam
okay King
are sure you can afford it you're gonna
owe Brian Kavanaugh like 700 better just
spend it now million dollars spend it
before he can get it right true true
I'll see you in bankruptcy court
I'll pay you when you pay me
my I know I'm supposed to be retaining
this my skin but my my Avatar costume is
like kind of choking me a little bit
I think it it's the Scorpion chair it's
like it's pinching the bottom and it's
like pulling back and into it just you
can cut it
it knows that it's [__] it's my body
dude the chair knows [__] dumb stupid
shut up Zach I'm an anger stupid shut up
Zach all right can I do this show I mean
what's going on what has happened you've
been spending the last 15 minutes guys
stop interrupting the 50 minutes
guarantee you
people thought that was entertaining
swear to God
it used to be my favorite part is when
you guys would talk about what you would
eat there it is
you know what I mean it's interesting to
look at the menu and stuff all that
entertaining
on the topic of uh the Avatar costume
can I give a quick beat uh hold on I
want to apologize to ELA for saying shut
up even though it's a sound bite I
shouldn't say that go ahead cam what the
[__] I'm sorry uh can I give a quick PSA
to the gentleman in um
the Avatar costume I had to go pee
earlier and I didn't want to take off my
shirt and because it opens from the back
so you can rip the leg
and then slide it all the way up and
then get your second tail out that way
oh that's smart I just cut a dick hole
in mine did you do really yeah I did
it's covered by the cloth
good thing you got the one shot cam you
need to go say this in front of if you
go see Avatar again just go down in
front of the screen everybody before you
even take a piss before you do it
guys
can we wrap this up
the Avatar pain combo
we're waiting we're waiting on the
results of the poll do Navy's pee blue
77 yes by the way how bad you have to
pee right now dude Navi
urinate do they urinate at all do they
even have dicks the way of water oh they
definitely [__] with their tails I love
all right guys thank you here's an
article I'm interested in Avatar this is
important it's from Roger ebert.com
Roger Ebert is dead dude he doesn't care
about evidence I'm beyond the grave he's
talking about Navi sex
there's a gene uh Cisco gun article
no guys
that wasn't his speed wrap it up
do navies wrap it up when they have sex
they were
I think they have I think they have such
command of their own biology that they
can decide not only if the impregnation
works but the guys after the
conversation okay if you all want to
have your little Avatar sewing Circle or
[__] gang bang whatever you do you
guys got the Avatar gangbang with your
ponytails blue see now you're getting
it's a fictional character I'm curious
it doesn't matter I mean I feel like an
avatar point they gotta shoot blue loads
right yeah you're feeling a little blue
curious aren't you
a blue job there you go
let me see if the uh James Cameron
Avatar fandom.com just because people
thought my Wendy's ordering was
entertaining doesn't mean that this
conversation is entertaining Dan Abby's
got blue I had a sense for the flow of
this show and what the audience want and
this is not one of them stop it okay
[Music]
stop
blue curious
all right thank you let's move on
speaking of what the audience wants
Avatar is killing it at the box office
that's right number one in the world
guys that's not even relevant I mean
okay I know it's doing very well I don't
care
7.8 out of 10 on IMDb what a rating
that's pretty 7.8 that's not you know
what that's not even worth discussing
it's mediocre it's mid oh
that's because they're they're getting
brigaded by haters like you and Zach I
have not voted before if I did I give it
a one when they're uh when they get
embarrassed and you know like my face
turns red do they turn purple
foreign
all right I'll just let me know when you
guys are done
I'll talk to tick tock or something well
according to fanfiction.net
apparently Navi can blush but obviously
let's talk Canon so I mean it's dot net
oh okay I got one I got one what do they
call blue balls
is there red balls right because that's
just like they just dropped the balloon
they're always they're just in a
Perpetual state of blue balls
what would what would
all right well everybody enjoyed Avatar
2. I'm super happy for them anyway a lot
to get to so moving on to Logan Paul
figuring out the universe oh good
finally we get to talk about Logan Paul
even Logan do it Logan wogan Oh my god
well maybe Avatar 2 is what God Dan's
the type of Avatar to say blue lives
matter that's right
can y'all stop please can you see my
bulletproof vest earlier yeah I'm one of
the Maga
dude you're like Pandora great again
blue what do you call a cop Avatar a Bab
you know the cops are like the boys and
blues are they boys in red
you know yeah maybe they may be red I
don't think that Navi you guys haven't
funny anymore stop I don't think they
have a system of uh modern policing on
Pandora I'm leaving at that actually
blue color blue color open up this Logan
post it solves all questions that we
have it solves everything actually okay
let's take a look now av's trying to
maybe he's trying to steer the
conversation thank you somebody [__]
cares about this show
you guys didn't mention Avatar one yeah
that movie sucked I love Avatar one I'm
here for Avatar one really yeah I
[__] hated the first one but they
want me over the first second one all
right we you've said that like 10 times
on this show Dan now today you talk
about me not today myself I get it Dan
you like Avatar you didn't like the
first one
today I don't want to talk about Avatar
one or two whales what I do want to talk
about is the future movies titles have
been leaked Ian was talking about that
earlier I want to talk about feet Bleak
they didn't come out like once every
decade but they filmed them all at once
hold on I don't care Cameron I don't
care I don't care
can't wait to see Avatar 3 the seed
Bearer that's disgusting that is kind of
gross let me get my seed all over the
place that's [__] gross
stop okay it's not funny people are
saying move on now okay you guys are you
guys are damaging the Integrity of the
show
Logan Paul just for the record I did not
see that in the chat a single time just
to clarify
um
I well you're switching how are you even
looking at the chat bro
how can you even look at the chat oh do
you have no idea DeAndre yeah just said
move on we gotta move on
Deandra
DeAndre the same move on you can do a
poll and that's not do it no that's not
no do you understand do you guys want to
start an avatar podcast on your own
[__] Channel and do it at 3am
actually no because I don't want you
staying up late it's going to affect
your job you can do it at from 8 to 8 30
p.m only maybe we could do it in
parallel to be honest things you don't
usually do that much well that's kind of
what you're doing right now bro I'm
saying all right stop it
Logan Paul had his first joint
this man is so [__] embarrassing
the all the controversies I think really
[__] with them
this dude really thinks he's like uh a
beautiful mind or some [__]
I figured out the universe
uh-huh this is the kind of cringe that
actually gives me physical pain I'm
trying to think but nothing happens
he has an infinite sign he says infinite
is a concept doesn't exist in the
natural universe is that a great start
that is an asterisk God
right I don't think I'm not a
mathematician but I don't think that
that's true
I think it's debated I I there's a
debate as if the universe is infinite or
finite
no but he's not talking about if the
he's just saying Infinity as a concept
doesn't exist
well what does that mean that's what I'm
saying I'm I'm saying right off the bat
we're already I think a little bit off
the rails because it definitely does
well I think what he means is does
infinite Express itself in the natural
world
right or is it just something we've
thought of in our minds okay well
you're giving him a little bit more
credit than me well you know he's he is
a he is a genius and deserves respect
that's true
he is actually nominated for the Nobel
Prize in mathematics and and uh
theoretical physics in the Millennium
prize
they won the Nobel Prize
infinite is a concept it doesn't exist
in the natural language yeah so that's
debated actually you know what's
interesting lately the scientists think
that the universe is finite it's not
actually infinite like previously
thought
uh yeah I I think it's theorized that
that maybe but I mean it's like it's so
theoretical it's like whatever
then he goes severe circle is the
god-shaped celestial bodies that one is
a little uh how do I say schizo
right it's like a little I hate to use
that word because I don't want to defame
uh our screen uh
Destiny a video game
The Traveler maybe I wanted to say it's
a little bit psychosis he's experiencing
you know what I mean
he was just he was playing Destiny and
he got really high
he thought he had some sort of
Revelation severe or circle is the
god-shaped celestial bodies like I just
I missed the equation beforehand where a
circle could equal God
I think he's saying that select because
celestial bodies are all round
therefore it's
divine
it's like titties like titties thank God
and nipples around oh titties are
roundish oh
you know what's interesting though
um
a lot of planets are not actually round
perfectly round they're oblong because
of the gravity and spinning I think all
I don't I don't think they're perfect
spheres they're not um they're not at
all interesting actually a lot of them
there's like uh it's more like a golf
ball shape with the divots and ridges
and it's more oblong than it's perfectly
spherical
so I don't know if that how that factors
into the god equation breasts
um
are you guys cringing yet this is crazy
right yeah I mean this is literally like
sophomore year my first joint I I yeah
and then you get sober and read it and
go dude that's embarrassing he didn't
you got he posted this seems a little
more like shroomy to to me than weed but
but perhaps perhaps
I have to assume Logan smoked weed
before
right yeah I think he said once that he
was he was smoking a lot yeah this seems
like a like a mushroom trip taken too
far
he says uh let's see the universe is
likely finite okay we touched on that
and contained and spherical
I don't know that it's spherical I think
that's debated there's lots of theories
about that what the shape of the
universe is it could be like a spider
web kind of shape it could be curved
over itself it being spherical even a
theory that it's uh somewhat flat like a
disc a flat right this is 2D yeah
there's a theory that says that
everything the third dimension is just
like a projection
maybe loss for words right now yeah so
that that that is not uh that is not
known time equals infinite so here he
contradicts himself he says
I didn't actually expect to break this
down
I'm enjoying it I'm going to following
the uh the shroom logic here so he says
time does not express itself naturally
but then he says time is infinite so
that is but he's questioning that is
time infinite okay right eventually All
Stars will die equals no more light okay
he death of the universe yes entropy
bruh got it got it
did you know that stars were all burned
out one day
what
if the universe is contained
has an end can we assume
Apple in a box Theory
he's a little too advanced for me I am
not familiar with the app I don't know
what the [__] the app I'll be honest I
don't know
can you get me a yeah
I gotta I gotta familiarize myself here
yeah
can we get some apple in the box please
uh what's up okay thank you glorious
doof Legend uh Katie says I'm also
having Wendy's Legend it's an expression
of infinity it suggests uh one iteration
that if Apple was left in a box for
billions of years that its fundamental
particles would theoretically go through
every possible State change and then
eventually return to its original state
I'm sure he's super a long enough
timeline yeah
cool
so the Apple oh somebody said it's that
Netflix documentary about Infinity oh
this is okay he sat down and watched
this he watched something and now he's
like an expert okay gotta go now he's
like a deep thinker right
okay so we got an apple in a box
um
when everything is dead and dust
becomes a dense collection of matter
because of gravity black holes
everywhere
okay
the universe essentially collapses in on
itself that is a huge leap that is a
huge [__] leap there bro
universally collapses in itself high
density and temperatures Big Bang
that I mean listen
I think it's I think it's interesting
that you think you're the first person
to thought about this obviously
I don't want to discourage people from
having fun thought experience what if
he's right what if he's right well yeah
because he well this was the
predominantly predominant theory of the
universe the Big Crunch about you know
20 years ago I think most most physics
physicists are it's off that at this
point yeah it's out
it's a nice thought though
and I like his mini diagram of the Apple
in the box there it is there's the apple
he did a little like shiny Speck on the
Apple so that right there's a light
source yeah you know the uh the the
layout here from a design perspective I
don't hate is kind of aesthetically
pleasing to look at his psychotic
ramblings he's probably gonna so it is
an nft next oh maybe very dark brown
what was that movie 22 remember that
with Adam or [__] Jim Carrey he was
like psycho just writing [__] oh did you
get a picture of that three was it 23 I
think yeah something like that the
number 23. I see 23 everywhere
right right right right
yeah the number 23.
yeah I mean obviously
I wanted to be the big uh the big crunch
but
as far as evidence goes that's not the
predominant Theory right now
unfortunately here's Logan by the way
well as he writes this up
I see the chat's very
the chat's agreeing with me they're
admiring the penmanship the layout
really yeah no I mean it's it's it's a
pleasing uh document that he's put
together Kim blueberry
you've got to compliment him for
something I guess
so the bear
he goes the universe uh black holes are
everywhere
Universe collapses on itself
I don't understand how that
because the black holes are going to be
spread out like billions of light years
you left me in a black hole of rage and
confusion well it seems that he's not
buying into the uh entropic uh heat
death theory of the universe where
everything keeps expanding and because
if black holes by their nature or you
know matter that gets condensed yeah so
tightly that it creates a singularity so
for there to be black holes everywhere
it would have to be a crunch type
situation that's going on well no that
no that is the theories that at and by
the end of the universe there will be
black holes everywhere as stars exhaust
their fuel and collapse in on themselves
black holes radiate energy it's called
Hawkins radiations and they will over
the course of trillions Years also
evaporate burnout right yeah burnout
uh so we got a big bang universe repeats
itself life is a cycle we become the
Apple
again
conclusion nothing matters oh thanks bro
all that for that
oh nothing matters except love had the
[__] I
a little bit of a leap there not that I
disagree but where how did this come
from this Theory
all that matters is love aren't you the
guy that like just ruined people's life
with the dumps this crypto Zoo scam
thank you
love love love cut to Coffee zillow's
video I lost fifty thousand dollars
five hundred thousand dollars I love
baby
and then Logan's like who what kind of
idiot this guy did crypto scams and his
son invested [__] idiot love love
love
a force of defense in court he's gonna
try to confuse the [__] out of the jury
oh
you think we're laying the seeds for an
insanity plea here yeah interesting
I also love is a force of attraction
similar to gravity
okay any questions I agree with that too
do you think we could use this as a him
endorsing loves Visa
oh
[Music]
so true
love is a force of attraction similar to
gravity
Let's uh let's ask Mike let's ask Mike
maybe he can get a
in Logan's ear and get us a Visa
recommendation yeah I mean if he's if
he's off the rails maybe we can convince
him yeah
just tell him it's for like I don't know
a crypto it's it's an offer to promote
some crypto on Twitter or something yeah
yeah I [__] my pants today here's Logan
Paul writing love is like gravity
crunching all the numbers
but
hold on black holes and wormholes you
haven't mentioned wormholes yet laws of
physics no longer apply
that's not true to wormholes that is
true to singularities of black holes
wormholes are actually predicted
by just recently nice big news about
that yeah isn't that interesting they
were able to simulate one in a quantum
computer really they didn't know that or
last year yeah it's kind of a trip
so laws of physics no longer apply
so yeah actually the laws of physics do
apply theoretically to a wormhole it's
just the bending of time space
the Multiverse how the [__] you get to
that
yeah we're going off the rails a little
bit but who what created and why God
okay all right Standing Ovation all
right
we did it awesome bro
Checkmate atheists he literally did all
this just to be like we don't know and
it's God it's like yeah everybody's been
saying that for like the entire history
of humanity bro you didn't you didn't
revolutionize anything if you're just
getting [__] for making fun of his
co-host for uh believing in God
oh interesting I found God bro I feel
like this has to be something
bigger like an nft project like Cam said
I don't think he made it honestly
really did yes he did nah uh but but he
thinks you're good hold on hold on you
think that he's like this is dope I want
to post it and pretend I wrote it
yeah
or it's it's like a merch line or some
dumb [__] somebody said this is
literally the Netflix doc the doc ends
with love is his conclusion too so um
yeah I really I think
took some mushrooms sat down watched a
Trippy documentary took some notes took
some notes threw it up on Twitter I
think that's the most likely explanation
let's read the comments I thought he had
a test yeah where'd you get your shrooms
from
all right here let's read the quote
tweets those are usually good
Greek philosophers be like I don't know
about that when you're far Loco deep
and just left the rave
this guy just said f yourself which is
not nice we don't like that okay
you have the Intel careful of this on
screen Ian you never know with these
threads this guy says you have the
intelligence of a microwaved toddler
never heard that actually very specific
it's probably pretty low I remember my
first time on LSD somebody said
time Cube for 11 year olds that was what
I when we sent this in our chat I
immediately linked the time Cube website
because it reminded me of that time Cube
guys is actually
interesting that guy rules yeah he's
kind of interesting
okay I thought that was fun we talked
about it way more than I thought we
would
also something happened over the weekend
amaranth friend of the show had a big
party to celebrate her birthday
and the crew went there
you guys had fun right
yeah for the most part a lot of fun was
that your first like La scene party
um
yeah I think for me personally because
it was like it sounds like it was kind
of like La scene-ish yeah which means
like there's just like a lot of
yeah influencers and or models or
wannabe models people who are tagging
along hoping to meet someone famous to
advance whatever they're working on
stuff like that did you guys get that
Vibe definitely yeah definitely yeah
yeah we had a lot of fun there was a
dude in like a Benjamin Franklin outfit
who kind of like creeped out Lena but
besides that I saw that guy what he put
his armor on Lena on the hot tub not
cool wait wait who it was he uh you know
Ben Franklin okay
I don't know lightning guy
you know that guy
where was this cross posted to hey uh
I'd like to present you guys uh what's
the name a vote because boobs chill baby
so this was awesome though xqc was there
doing uh content and uh well just watch
this is great
um hey
hey AB we do for a living I work for the
H3 podcast this is Asian podcast [__]
this guy uh I'm just kidding my name is
Cameron I work for the H3 podcast [__]
me dude oh okay same guy um anyway uh
moving on
inside here this is
um yeah uh I like this I like this it's
really nice um maybe one day when I'm
comfortable with um showing my dick
anyway um
Sam nice to meet you Sam what are you
for living H3 podcast
um I'm just kidding what's your name I'm
Olivia Olivia once again uh what'd you
do for learning I work for the H3
podcast
okay I'm out of here
um that's right [__] you better watch
your [__] back we're out there
you guys put on a menacing Aura I trust
yeah no I I we talked to him beforehand
a little bit me and Ian and he was
really nice to us you know who we were
but I found that funny that we had him
surrounded
yeah that's more pie by the way for also
a friend of the show you guys were
hanging out with her right yeah we hung
out there you guys got dinner afterwards
we did lunch next day and then the next
day after that me Lena and Cameron and
her hung out very nice oh my goodness
it was such a cool experience the whole
thing like I was just in awe when we
first got to the house and everything
was so was so nice and luxurious
great experience other than that the the
Ben Franklin guy
um it was just it was a weird situation
like so I was in the tub with all the
girls and then he got in and he put his
arm around me I thought maybe he's
because of the way he was dressed I
thought maybe he's um like part of the
broadcast or the sponsor so I didn't
want to kill it for everyone and I just
smiled and played along but then a b
brought me a pizza and so I asked
everyone in the tub I'm like anyone want
some and he said he did and he told me
to feed it to him ew what a freak and I
just like he put me on the spot I didn't
know what to say there's like I'm in
this tub with all of these huge
streamers and it's currently like live
streaming right now I didn't want to you
know
um so it was just it was super awkward
and then I got out after that but other
than that it was it was it was a great
experience I'm really sorry that
happened that's okay I don't I'm not
even like any hate towards him or
anything it was just like super weird no
uncomfortable though I saw well I know I
open the stream at one point and I saw
that Ben Franklin guide like in front of
the camera just being a like a troll in
the worst way
yeah you
do me on the spot and I
know Rory Hicks by the way says that
Logan stole his religious text from the
mole Folk
aurori is our mole folk representative
he is he's always talking about the mole
people don't we have a picture of when
he put the armor out or the video of it
I don't think Lena wants to see it oh
you don't show it yeah yeah it's fine it
would yeah Alina went to the car after
she
wasn't uh
yeah I mean it didn't look like
yeah no you didn't do anything wrong it
wasn't like weird part yeah yeah I just
I was I felt uncomfortable especially
with the whole pizza thing I didn't like
that feed me
freak yeah
I'm just like in the I'm the most
insignificant person there you know all
these huge streamers and I didn't want
to like ruin it for everyone Ben
Franklin I thought he was part of the
like the the sponsor or something
because why else was he dressed like
that yeah you know what I gotta say
Dan saved that guy's life I'll tell you
why me yeah I'll tell you why because
initially we're gonna go that costume
we're gonna go to that party dressed as
avatars meet Ian we had two of the
costumes early and then Dan's like it's
gonna kill the bear but it's up to you
guys if you want to wear we're like yeah
you're right we'll wear it if I would
have wore that costume I would have got
down with Ben Ben Franklin I'm not going
to fight someone dressed as Ben Franklin
when I'm dressed normal but if I was in
an avatar outfit it might have [__]
went you think you might have got got
away with it I think so or you just have
that kind of like you just give him the
property of the navi because he's nine
foot tall powerful blue man at that
point yeah
but no it was it was nice having the
whole crew there I wouldn't have enjoyed
it uh just with myself I mean everyone
else is really nice amaranth was great
everyone else there was really cool but
it's nice having the uh the family with
us amaranth was super nice she invited
me I see some people saying why didn't I
go obviously you guys know I don't go
anywhere
I was putting the kids to bed and I was
watching the live stream when Teddy was
falling asleep
and that's when I saw the Benjamin
Franklin guy
but I'm glad you guys had fun yeah
Emirates super nice uh she's she's great
she was really sweet yeah here's a list
um
as kids that's true I was with Teddy
putting him to bed longest day ever
no babysitter
doesn't leave house social anxiety
a billion other stuff never intended to
go can I uh push back on the viewership
real quick I saw a lot of comments
saying that we were clout chasers for
going to this party and not going
together
yeah okay good but I gotta say Gabe was
invited to this party and we were
getting asked all night get where's Gabe
at where's Gabe at so he was invited and
he didn't show up to this one too oh my
God that's good see Cameron what have
you done the team they just killed
probably 50 people their heads just
[__] pop have turned but we will be
going to Gabe's party this year
oh definitely so apparently amaranth
invited Gabe yes that's awesome and he
was he was he would have loved that
party man agreed he was being
specifically requested too like where's
Gabe at
the wow that was a strong one
more pie donated she says Lena you were
the most iconic person in that whole hot
tub oh my God I love her it was so great
getting to meet her too and then hanging
out with her all weekend she was
seriously so sweet yeah there it is
morgue pie ladies and gentlemen
so overall you all had a good time yeah
but it seems like y'all yeah I know it
was a really cool experience
that's cool
you guys got it man all the celebs there
love was super jealousy you guys got to
meet xqc yeah the king juicer
I want to meet my juicer
one day love one day I'm gonna bring you
I just love after this I'm gonna [__]
sponsor you and bring you out here and
you're gonna end up like stalking him or
something crazy
no no no breaking into his house with a
[__] uh blender
I hope that wasn't awkward you know I'm
just messing around on stream I'm like
no you're good
it doesn't seem like he's the type to
hold a grudge
xqc is never awkward
what the [__]
carrot I heard someone say why does he
talking like he's doing on auction he
always talks like an auctioneer
it's Samsung I think Sam was the one
that sent this clip the other day I'm
sending it in Maine but of him on stream
and this killed me I don't know why this
little 20 second clip I'll watch that
I'm gonna finish this
um
um yeah yeah recently um honestly you
don't know um there's a little bit of a
drama with H3 in a minute comment about
them that was like kind of rude but um
they're all here now but okay oh yeah he
called
he's a sweet guy you know what I'm gonna
squash the beef with him yes he's like
it's bro I don't care he called he said
that I looked he was reacting to the QD
Cinderella thing and he said that I
looked like a possum under his house
yeah the old possum on the side of his
house and I said that's fair I see it
I didn't even think it was necessarily
insult I said yeah I see it I
I think possums are cute I'm gonna come
out and say it I know a lot of people
find them absolutely disgusting
but they're just scary because they're
kind of like when you see him at night
and the like the eyes are kind of
glowing at you I understand why it's
kind of scary but I mean like no they're
they I well the thing is like they're
used they're used to be one in my
neighborhood when I was a kid and I
would go to take the trash out and it
would it's like pretty big it's like the
size of a cat and you would scowl at me
from like five feet and I would freak
the [__] out and run so
there they scare me but yeah I mean
they're cute all mammals are cute at the
end of the day really aren't they look
at this one with all the babies yeah the
babies are so cute
yeah they're pretty cool animals though
so thank you xqc for the compliment yeah
there you go that's how I uh broke the
ice I went up I said you called my boss
a possum do you know what I'm talking he
went H3 and I was like he looks exactly
like a possible right thanks bro
so you guys bonded over hating me
but he said I hope I didn't create any
weird beef or drama with you guys of
course How Could You excuse me how thank
you we love excuse you folks don't we we
love them
no I'm ready to start my friendship Arc
with xqc
let's go read uh
Evan I say that at the same time sure
did what happened
we both said let's go
these guys uh what was it mad but
whatever
whatever I'm not gonna ask
I got the feeling from watching the
stream that xqc was trying to Mac on her
a little bit well it was the chat was
shipping them oh really yeah the chat
was shipping them heavily oh yeah here's
what I remember I was watching the
stream and then morgue pie kind of
awkwardly went up to him and introduced
herself
it was only awkward because execute was
like hi nice to meet you he seemed a
little smitten and then he like
immediately turned his attention away
from her and since she walked off I just
saw this scene I was like that was a
little awkward hmm
but uh morgue pie
if you were if you're we can probably
set this up for you I don't know
I could try we're in real tight with xcc
well I'm trying to get I'm trying to be
best Dr I doubt she would need our help
yeah absolutely no way does she need her
I don't know xcc is pretty awkward you
know I mean okay she said it I wanted it
and he didn't I knew that that she
wanted it not not that he but we talked
about it I saw her go up to me like
introduce herself I was like he didn't
want it huh
okay hmm
interesting she said I tried to raise
and he rejected me oh she tried the risk
brutal wait where is she typing that to
you uh I see it in chat
um
she said get me up in that I don't know
man you tried to Riz it and it didn't
work so
I'm not sure I can help you much further
than that
I can introduce you to White claw Gabe
Mark pie deserves someone Who's Gonna
Worship her
yeah yeah yeah that's all that's not
going to be a problem
here's the H3 podcast according to xqc
by the way
[Music]
[Laughter]
so you know what guys let xqc know
bestie Arc is on the way and I'm gonna
apologize to you I hope I didn't cause
too much drama and problems for you my
dear friend xqc
here's a friend of the show he called in
what's his real name
Felix oh another Felix another Felix
um so there was that that was fun
also
what is this just a picture yeah yeah
I've seen that
so
um nice glad you guys had fun
you know
here's xqc with the gang
you guys reported that he was very nice
giving Aaron Carter a little bit
rip to the goat I have to I have to say
it was uh Under the Sea themed and I
think we were the only ones in that's
why I have an octopus on my head not a
single other person besides our group
had anything under the sea really oh
yeah everyone's too L.A cool to dress up
on themes you know what xqc looks like
just just a friendly response to the
possum comparison
he looks like that hold on let me pull
it up
he looks like this [__]
this xqc right here
oh my God Sid
this is you bro
[Laughter]
and Ice Age is a great movies you know I
like oh such a good read oh [__] thanks
yeah love it you have a you have an
ability who was it recently that you you
spotted as like the red furry guy from
Looney Tunes and it was like so [__]
accurate
I remember the big like red hairy guy
from I remember I know the character I
don't remember who I said looks like
that though somebody in the chat will
remember it was recent so a yeah so
here's a funny clip of xqc our friend of
the show it's going viral they need to
take why is XC allowed to play Hogwarts
Legacy
no one got mad when I screamed it they
just they were mad that I picked the
wrong house yeah well I think people
need to watch your stream to get mad
about it oh damn oh Jesus
[Music]
sorry I don't know why I've been
annihilated
Time come back but I'm not gonna no you
no I'm not what do you got then I got
nothing yeah okay I only got what you
give
no that's not true people watch your
stream yeah
oh people were oh it was liver King it
was liver King post steroids that you
identified as he had the energy of the
Looney Tunes character
right
thank you
here it is let's give this one a try
a character
okay so I mean there's a lot to unpack
here Channel
s was he joking or serious it seems very
serious like love you you know this guy
better than anyone is these shirts are
kidding yeah it's probably serious yeah
that's the beauty of it does he not a
character why does he say character
hey he has an accent just like me
right that's fair
that's awesome that I like that the
alternate World of Harry Potter where
they use carrots instead of Wands
this game looks fun as [__] though maybe
I it is
really does it it does it looks really
good it sort of it gives me sort of like
Elden it's not Elder ring level of
course is it open world yes and it's
like a roll it's like a RPG yeah that
sounds fire you don't play as Harry
Potter you're just in the Harry Potter
World yeah yeah it's like 100 years
before I just yeah that's it I'm just a
hater I've never
we've we've discussed this but Harry
Potter xqc this could be us if you stop
playing around
let's make it happen
yes sorry about that Joe baby no I don't
mind AB actually is a great twitch
streamer you guys should check it out
[Applause]
oh thank you he's streaming Hogwarts
Legacy apparently thank you thank you
you're making calling me all you want if
I'm gonna keep getting plugs yeah my
work friends are the only people I'm
subscribed to on Twitch that's why
shut up are you giving them your Prime
absolutely are you kidding how you
decide who gets it
I haven't decided who got something you
don't know what I'm talking about I
don't know what you're talking about I
just know that I I do not get ads got it
very good
um yeah everybody go watch a b and and
then baby start killer shame him for
playing this transphobic game can you
say it like that A B Star kill on Twitch
let's clip that
you're gonna clip it what are you gonna
do with it
Legacy
anyway yeah I can't shame on UAB shame
on you wow
we've been through enough haven't trans
people didn't do enough
there's a trans character in the game
oh
well that's great that's pretty
Progressive isn't it yeah in the Marvel
Universe I guess the question is does it
do they counsel each other out I think
maybe they do I don't know yeah it's not
for me to say Yeah well yeah something
tells me JK Rowling didn't have too much
to do with the development of this video
game I think she just sits in her castle
and tweets all day at this point
actually I actually saw a thing about
the trans character in the game and I
couldn't tell if it was a meme or not
does it really have like
kind of yeah where's that kind of like a
sus name
so some people are talking about the
name but the name actually it means
rebirth I believe in some kind of
Mythology oh okay interesting came from
I I really couldn't discern if people
were just like patrolling or not with
what I was saying
I do want to play that game but
I mean I don't stream it anyway
but I actually do you think that it's
actually this is a big conversation is
obviously a sport trans rights so is it
antithetical just wearing trans rights
by by playing that I well if you buy it
and so she gets money so do you you know
want to boycott her and not give her
money it's like I mean that's all it
really I mean it's already like a
billionaire yeah I mean it's not gonna
make like a huge difference in our
bottom line right how many [__]
people worked on that game of course
made the game a labor of love including
Trends people worked on the game
okay that's good interesting and like
she's not even involved like who who
cares that she makes money she gonna she
makes money when you [__] take a [__]
at this point yeah it's like trying to
protest Disney I mean of course I
support the trans Community but like
everything that we have on our daily our
iPhones you know child labor you know
everything
is rooted in some kind of you know
[__] up evil so yeah that is true we
give money to lots of bad things in our
life without a second thought so that is
that is a fair point so we are saying we
are giving the green light
on Hogwarts Legacy
I won't be playing it personally I might
get but I also [__] hate Harry Potter
so that was never it's a non-issue for
me so it just looks like sick it's like
a big AAA game right like they worked a
lot yeah yeah it's yeah it's a big game
the combat is it's super fun it's a lot
of fun oh yeah dude
Ellie I'm actually super glad Harry
Potter's not in a dumb over his dumbass
[__]
um I don't you sent me a Hassan tweet
but I can't read it so it's private is
that Taja Dodger I don't know hassano's
been getting a lot of hate for what I
what did he do nothing I don't
understand why people are not playing it
yeah he's he's not and he's still got
[__] he suggested I think at one point
he suggested he wanted to play it and do
like a gameplay fundraiser something
like he he's done the past where like
every time he dies he donates some money
to like a trans charity or something to
like offset that but I think he got a
lot of [__] for that So eventually it
was just like fine I won't play it but
now I think he's still getting [__]
about it and it's just like I don't know
that dude can't win I mean you know how
it is it's the same with you it's like
yeah yeah the same I can't win no matter
what I do I I donated a hundred thousand
[__] dollars from my own pocket and
that sprung a whole conspiracy of hate
videos about how it was fake but you
know it's like it's crazy
um I did see a clip of him saying I I'm
just not gonna play it because people
can get mad at me if I do
people get mad at me if I don't he's
like I'm just not gonna play it just to
avoid he said I've never felt worse at
any point in my career than I do now at
the heels are almost raising one million
dollars oh I forgot to mention I donated
at ten thousand dollars to his campaign
you need to mention that
yeah uh I hate the left I hate the right
I literally want to quit the only thing
keeping me going is not caving to
psychos I mean I've been there bro
yeah I think he's having a tough week
oh by the way leftovers is not happening
because he's doing some twitch things so
but um so yeah there's no episode
tomorrow
you know there was even a website that
was tracking who was playing the game
which streamers were playing it but it
got taken down or removed
by Hill
I'm not sure I'm not sure the details
yeah I'm not trying to boast or anything
but I if you go to top donors
I am on this list
of donating ten thousand and one dollars
of course so that I could be on the top
the top of these
let's face it I don't want to say that
they weren't generous but at a certain
point you just got to acknowledge that
I'm higher up on the list
five dollar uh I was wondering what the
one is for that's so funny yeah um that
that twelve thousand five hundred dollar
donation right there Anonymous that's me
I cam why are you lying it's me gotcha
uh
okay wow super generous show me the
receipt
I'll show you after the show
yeah I don't like I did donate it but
not 12 000. oh let me Photoshop
something real quick yeah I don't I
don't like to brag or boast or anything
obviously I did it for the the Turkish
and the Syrian people who are devastated
horrible tragedy
but it is nice to see it up there right
there in the top five
it looks good yeah and I I did want to
tell you guys about it
because uh yeah you didn't
what you didn't want to mention it I
didn't want to mention on the show but I
thought in the context of what we were
talking about was important uh
atmospheric
yeah yeah right you think it would be
smart to put maybe the YouTube url
instead of Ethan Klein
could generate some traffic it's too
late it's too late but that would have
been a good idea follow me on subscribe
to my channel on YouTube
that's what they did above you
I thought that was right this is a promo
I think so telegram or maybe probably
not I don't want to I don't wanna
probably not it's not very clear if it
is so it's probably not yeah actually I
saw his song gave 25k I was like oh [__]
okay I got a pony up
super sad though I don't really want to
get into it in depth because it's just
dude the videos are so nuts so I'm like
[__] up yeah
not not at all I mean not at all to try
and make it about Americans or anything
but having
uh lived through a major earthquake not
and not as big as that not even close
yeah I mean it was ten times bigger than
the Northridge earthquake that happened
when Ethan and I were
and that is I mean burned in my memory
is one of the most traumatic things
that's ever happened to me and this is
10 times as big I I can't even fathom
two yeah and two back to back I don't
think people who don't live in like
earthquake uh territories understand
just how massive a 7.8 earthquake is
that is like
insane
[Music]
yep it's pretty wild that [__] scares me
a lot because in Sweden there's like
nothing that can kill me nature of ice
no animals no natural disaster what
about Norwegian people
Norwegians are fine but the Danes yeah
but yeah nothing like
it scares me very much to go to L.A when
it comes to that kind of stuff I mean
it's a very rare thing obviously
we're due for a big one yeah but not to
scare you away but
yeah the difference is that La things
are built with wood which is more
flexible and also things are just kind
of newer like as I understand in Turkey
a lot of this are in Syria a lot of the
stuff that collapsed was kind of like
hastily built and not up to code and
stuff because like really old stuff yeah
um stuff
because they're already struggling and
it's it's just [__] tragic when this
stuff happened it's so sad
so my heart goes out to the Turkish and
Syrian people and all affected you guys
want to donate it is this this blew my
mind did you see about this
this Castle 2 000 year old castle got
destroyed in the earthquake I've been
there for
before Jesus walked the Earth this
Castle has been standing there man just
devastated
it's insane
that is crazy
I mean those things are built to last
though God damn clearly
yeah [__]
what's the link what's the Easy Link to
shout out because this is like a weird
well Hassan's uh
fundraiser it's still go ongoing here
let me grab those I just want to know
the link so if people want to donate
they can we can put it in the
description Maybe
yeah but you know what I
I get the same [__] Hassan does it's
annoying you just can't win
no matter what you do I get really
frustrated by people on the left lately
sometimes because it's like there's
people on the left who
they expect from anybody perfection
you have to be absolutely perfect and if
there's a blemish if you've ever done
something wrong they want you to
it's like
they want you to be guilty forever
like there's no forgiveness purity test
stuff yeah
it's so gross yeah yeah it's
you know I don't even understand the end
goal of that kind of behavior that I see
like on the left specifically
were they criticize other leftist people
as not being Lefty enough like Hassan
for example
I mean they do it to me all the time too
it's like
I mean I think you know it's an
outgrowth of the fact that people on the
left are generally more
um
self-critical I you know people on the
right are much in my experience it seems
that they are much more willing to just
sort of
ignore uh contradictions or you know
uh
things that go against the narrative on
their side with other people
um for the sake of
clawing power you know they're they're
willing they're not
that that Purity stuff is not really
that important on uh on the right or as
important as it is to someone said Ethan
you're not a leftist how am I not a
leftist what am I
wait genuinely what do you think I am
even you're a liberal not a leftist oh
what okay
I don't know what the [__] that means
what what's the difference between a
leftist and a liberal well Anonymous
there is a difference uh generally
we have to get into it
I mean what do you want from me I I uh
in the parlance uh in the parlance of of
um thank you American politics Ethan is
definitely on the left I I understand
it's more nuanced than that and
especially in Europe uh the liberal
parties are generally considered center
right
um that is somewhat the case here in the
United States too you know the
Democratic Party by International
standards would probably be considered a
center-right party
um I do think that you're a Centrist
somebody called H3 Club Factory says
shout out by the way I'm trying to get
you uh you guys unbanned the H3
industrial complex ran into a snag they
thought they were impersonating me so
I'm working with YouTube to get that
resolved but yeah
um how am I a Centrist
actually oh no now people are saying I'm
far right okay I see
whatever who cares stupid labels
doesn't matter
I'm whatever's Pro blowing up okay oh my
God
I was gonna say fro blowing up
public Discord because we gotta blow
this discourse wide open baby that's
right conversation is everything
you know if we can work through anything
if only we come together and talk I'm
gonna explode on the scene with this
wonderful conversations
it's somebody in the chat said uh Ethan
should take a political COMPASS test you
know we actually did for leftovers once
and we didn't end up doing the segment
um but I remember Ethan's results uh
we're I'll take it live right now oh
Wendy's
here let's I'll do it live it takes a
while I I I think I could probably find
the results it was very left it was very
it was very left
um
libertarian left in the that normal
compass that everybody takes those
things are are kind of goofy and not
totally accurate but I mean it gives you
a good sense of at least the ballpark
you're in yeah let me see if I can dig
up the results from before
um we got a new white claw game classic
by the way Logan hey I really like this
um vertical he's got into of wishing
eulogizing eulogizing us he's very good
essence uh the dearly Departed
so here's a new one from Gabe
Logan how you doing I'm sorry your mama
had died during the Christmas holiday
[__] yeah
and I'm sorry that your mom died around
your birthday too [__] [__] yeah
you deserved better
I hope you feel better [__] me [__] yeah
sorry mom passed away and I want to wish
you the best Logan best wishes from the
white cloud game and I want to wish you
the best good luck and happy [__] yeah
hopefully things get better Logan I want
to wish you the best
you know
um I love the angle
also I I love going I'm sorry that your
wife and mom died I hope things get
better
I hope you get a new wife like this this
man's life is [__] decimated
oh my God I hope things get better for
you
uh he's the best man I'll tell you oh
bless his heart yo [__]
that is what club game everybody
oh we should have Gabe send hassano
Cameo that's a good idea
sorry about the Hogwarts Legacy
controversy woo
H baby [__] uh
uh maybe in like a week it's he seemed
pretty upset about it today so
they're being canceled for doing a
donation stream yeah I got all that bro
I'm telling you I
I donated a hundred thousand [__]
dollars and all I got was a grief for it
greedy yeah you're so greedy just on a
basic level of someone who didn't really
I wasn't involved in politics at all
before I moved out here
um seeing people like you know you and
Dan and Hassan who you know are always
arguing for the left their whole careers
and when you say one thing slip up or
say one thing that they don't like then
that's it they're fake ruthless yeah
they're phony
that's it I'm one bad day away from
being a grifter you'll see yeah
I gotta pee um I'll be right back and
then this is awesome so Mr Beast
you guys may know this guy he's blowing
up on Tick Tock Keith Lee oh you guys
know he must some of you all must know
him right yeah you know so he's been
like reviewing small business family
restaurants and it's very wholesome
content and everybody loves this guy and
so Mr Beast reached out or left a
comment and said review my chocolate
bars
and Keith responded said I will review
your chocolate bars under these
conditions I don't remember what he said
but Mr Beast agreed now when I saw this
I was like
I know those Chicago bars are not good I
mean they're mid and that's fine they're
like two dollar chocolate bars
but
my question was like I know this guy
he's not gonna love it so I was curious
how this was going to go down and I got
to say Keith kept it real
he gave them
mediocre scores and Mr Beast gets
visibly angry actually it's quite quite
good
uh just real quick before we move on too
far I found it this was your test result
so yeah very not authoritarian
very not right
I'm almost as I'll live as you can get
I'm almost in the bottom left
what's more live than that
pull on Anarchy
basically
I don't know I think it's the fact that
you keep calling it lib though that like
again it's it's a very loaded word
because it means different things in
different places yada yada I'm not at
the trenches that deep
and yeah I mean these aren't like an
end-all be all by by any means but I'm
no wonk you're no wonk and you're also I
don't think a Nazi I'm gonna go out and
I'm gonna go ahead and say it I don't
think Ethan finds a Nazi people I think
I don't think he's enough thank you for
coming out and saying that all right I'm
gonna go pee and then we'll watch this
video I'll be right back okay
you know what we're going to be talking
about in the meantime
oh that's a great idea but no Avatar
obviously
uh if I may quickly
um Jack Lewis live at the Roxy Zach
Lewis live at the Roxy May 13th tickets
are going hot like hot cakes
um yeah good time and uh is it actually
it's like it's Hot Cakes yeah
well I mean
[Music]
it's a weird thing to present at the box
office is pancakes how you got to get in
with that yeah I think going like
hotcakes
like if it's later in the afternoon the
hotcakes aren't necessarily flying off
the shelf they're like just kind of
cakes right it really just kind of
depends Zach can we come dressed like
this absolutely oh cool
then come as you are as Kurt Cobain
wrote
um but yeah Zach Lewis live at the Roxy
tickets are going like room temp cakes
no but they're hot but they're hot
they're hot it's a hot ticket it's gonna
be a great night and I'd love to see
everyone there so um
black Lewis live in Roxy I'll be there
I appreciate the love guys I'm from The
Rock seat okay Roxy or elsewhere Dan oh
I'm okay thank you thank you Navi girl
I've just had my garlic fries delivered
oh [__] thank you Sam the true zone is
now in Pandora people look at someone
teeth look at this brick you think they
have potatoes on Pandora
like yeah but they're blue
or blue those are my least favorite
segment when I'm not there ah we miss
you love yeah we do Mystery love yo this
thing looks I miss you guys too like an
atrocity
but I'm still gonna eat it
these fries are below average they're
not good but they smell really good this
is lettuce wrap a single piece of
lettuce that is lettuce right oh it's
brownish
Dan where did you get your food
uh Wendy's
Wendy's no
[__] got him
got him
man yeah that one was killed him with
that one love everybody got me dude look
his ass out he's killed him I went down
the wrong pipe
[__] ending on a high note
yeah at least I went out as I always
wanted to live as a blue you got me like
once four months ago so I had to
eventually that's fair that's right oh
they forgot my burger no did they forget
something else too
they forgot two other fries what the
[__]
[__] dumb ass bro
Sam's about to go [__] murder someone
Ethan do you want mine monster Brothers
you want the hot nugs stop it you guys
eat your food are you sure
I'll split them with you no surprise no
my fries are here oh
I got something but you saw how excited
I was and oh absolutely it's very
disappointing this is all because of you
and now this
is right
I didn't even get your burger
I have fries so I'm good but the fries
just say that it didn't arrive on the
Postmates thing we don't need to order
again
sure right I mean another one suffering
right now
I'm not taking anyone's food
yo
this looks crazy did you get the garlic
fries I got the Baconator fries oh okay
sorry guys are like too soggy
yeah you're just talking
good though
[Music]
do you guys ever pull one of these we
hit it hit the fry in the Frosty
oh yeah that's the Nuggets too I was
doing that right now
you're dipping your nuggets in there
I will say this burger is pretty good
oh you got that like [__] monstrosity
thing
that's pretty good dude I'm devastated I
know you are
I'm sorry
it's not fair how are you gonna fix it
Sam
we're gonna work again you're gonna get
the whole thing refunded
[Music]
[__] yeah
might take too long though
[Music]
well
been going for two hours
so we only we have about three hours of
the show left
so it should be fun
okay let's watch this video
we haven't made it at the top of the
show section have we I knew we wouldn't
because all this stuff was so juicy oh I
guess we did do the Kafka article so
whatever
I do want to talk about this Darman [__]
this is oh yeah super super compelling
also Leonardo's the rumor that Leonardo
DiCaprio is dating a 19 year old
right I think it's not true being our
DiCaprio it looks like
he's only dating a 23 year old
okay right okay people well he's not a
freak he's not dating a 19 year old it's
funny that 50 year old is so easy to
believe that
it's not hard to believe that he would
be dating a 19 year old he is dating a
23 year old I just think it's funny that
people are lying about the age
I mean they're both gross but 19 would
be like whoa dude that's crazy
23 is gross
there's a bit of word though isn't he
ashamed at this point
clearly not yo bro I'm at this high
school girl that I was hot as [__]
tonight
that's like work like it doesn't really
seem like it's the age of consent I
think he's I think he's so big it's like
Beyond I don't think he's cancelable you
know what I mean it's not that bad I
don't think he'll get canceled or
anything but I just think like at a
certain point you would read all this
[__] about yourself and just be kind of
embarrassed
yeah
that
good
he's like 50 years old
and he's never dated someone over 27.
when you go below 16 like 15 and stuff
like that that you know by all means
he's been hanging out with keemstar too
much you know at the club
all right here we go Mr bummer because
um
dude do you enjoy him as an actor I oh
he's great I love him he is good
I mean listen
I wish he'd stop doing that
yeah that'd be good
just settle down with the nice
you know
girl 20 years younger than you oh
donations passed one million 30 year old
that's not enough
by the way congratulations to Hassan
wait what I miss past one mill oh let's
[__] go
dude by the way easy that's crazy I hope
he knows
what a good thing he's done with that
did I mention I donated ten thousand and
one one yeah only ten thousand huh
and one
um
that's important to know
and to remember and to hold dear
Hassan this is what it the headline used
to be this Hassan raised a million
dollars Asterix Ethan Klein of which
Ethan Klein donated ten thousand and one
dollars to
hosts of leftovers raise a million
dollars
why don't we I we can share that the
host of leftovers
love it
why should I be fine on Hassan
[Laughter]
so thank you so you guys can just thank
me essentially
you're welcome
all right let's watch this video God
damn
so Mr Beast
I here it is
let's try them and rank them one to six
I'm gonna be completely honest totally
not biased because if it sells more I
make more money I'm gonna be honest and
I hope Jimmy is sitting next to me and
not getting his feelings hurt
let's do it let's start with that once
again
I've tried this chocolate it's as mid as
it gets dude
it's two dollar chocolate
how good could it be
but you know Jimmy's like
expecting this guy to Kiss the Ring like
everybody does
because milk chocolate it's just a milk
chocolate bar compare it to Hershey's
which I know you probably never eat
Hershey's because they're terrible never
met anyone that likes Hershey I love
that compare it to her she's the most
hated chocolate in the world compared to
dogs I mean compared to eating some
[__] dog [__] off the sidewalk it was
pretty good right
ten yeah compared to that I'd pick it
every time and how would you compare
that to one
it's a little too sweet to live with
that stop that I did a lot sweeter than
what I would like though seven I
remember that that it was way too sweet
um I'll take it yeah we're still
figuring it out that's a good start good
start all right you know
out of ten like that song like that
battle
in his world I think I mean if
something's really good it's going to be
in the nine range if it's like a seven
world I think that's like I'm not really
interested in I mean
Jimmy gets visibly upset already
all different flavors
I honestly think he would have given it
a lower rating
like that's a zero basically if he
wasn't involved the seven out of ten is
a zero that's what you're saying
I think it's more like a six or a five
but he's being generous
all right here I got it here
all right this is our Crunch bar
throwing his chocolate this is the one
you believe in yes
it's not crazy Jamie no no you don't
like Crunch bars I do like Crunch bars
but
again it's so sweet let me try this
maybe these are people are saying oh my
God this is good to me in the chat I
don't know every time I've seen one of
his
when he's really loves something he's
like 9.9 9.6 yeah he doesn't like it I
mean he is he's not promoting this
chocolate if you watch this I'm not
going to the store and buying that [__]
he's like it's too sweet seven
I'm not buying peace Beast bars
wait who's going to be wrecking them I
rated the first one so we're going
completely off
we're in too deep I rate this a 10 out
of 10. I give this at 11 out of 10. 7.2
out of 10. this is amazing this is
better than the milk
I'm totally not pies
that's better than me talking
what do I put this at I don't know
I wish I would hear interesting do you
like dark there's some part of me that's
like I'm so used to the being all
paranoid about the dogs getting food off
the ground now
when he threw it I keep thinking like I
hope there's not a dog in there better
pick that up
it's probably barely no cocoa in that
chocolate I've got that's true
this is the same thing but dark
chocolate what'd you say about him
that's my favorite my cameraman's
favorite is your favorite
keep in mind only five ingredients
infinitely healthier for you than the
normal thing out there also my favorite
so far okay yeah okay hold on this claim
is
I don't even think he can make this
claim like this might be some violation
that that is not true it's infinitely
healthier for you than the normal thing
out there I don't even know what the f
what are you talking about if any
healthier than what than anything out
there
like I don't know what you mean wow it's
healthier than salad dude
like some some Papa John's level
marketing right there there's obviously
a [__] ton of sugar in it
so
as I understand it that more cocoa there
is the healthier it is
cocoa has a lot of health benefits
actually
really yeah it's very very very healthy
there's been studies
huh
um published
about the positive effects of cocoa so
the more the better
what's this
we got their ingredients if you scroll
down yeah maybe just that it's organic
organic just to the bottom
six simple ingredients
cane sugar
cocoa butter
chocolate liqueur
milk
vanilla powder and puffed rice okay
milk that's another type of milk
I never understood why people advertise
candy as healthy like the whole point
with candy is it's not supposed to be
healthy right so true dude it's sugar I
feel like that's a uniquely American
thing
yeah it's very odd I've never heard that
in Sweden it's like
this is the healthy chocolate yeah what
the [__]
also my favorite so far okay yeah Rohan
got good taste here's the thing I didn't
realize you're a dark chocolate guy I'm
not a super dark chocolate guy I do love
dark chocolate but I'm more of a in the
middle Suite I don't like super sweet
yeah and the milk chocolate was super
sweet for me but this is perfect sugar
level it is bitter because again I like
dark chocolate so I give this a 7.8 out
of this okay I'm starting to understand
this man okay
I'm starting to think of this man out
there uh oh of course
you're gonna like this one right you
like salt
I just I'm gonna get rid of these I love
songs
no you just don't trust me you you like
he's angry right like I'm not I don't
think I'm
reading into it I've never seen him like
this I think he's hiding it as [__]
yeah there's chaos happening but he's
genuinely angry
her chocolate kind of guy yes I can read
the room the room is red
okay Jimmy not crazy but it is good I
love that and when you compare it to
Hershey's not crazy absolutely of course
when you compare it to Hershey's
obviously there's going to be ours and
chocolate that's like infinitely better
not even Artisan I mean
[__] there's some name brands that are
delicious
I agree I agree you know you are so
right I'm gonna slam this chair
Hershey's sucks
I give it eight out of two eight out of
ten that's I'll take it you know I
wasn't expecting to get hired in the six
it is a lot better than I was expecting
he's trying to save it
that's great I'm happy this is my
favorite one I'm very happy the sea salt
chocolate God bless you guys have an
amazing day can I flip the table to end
it by the way this is his kids chair and
table that's like the lore
so Jimmy's like destroying his kid's
[__] out of anger
I got all the feasible chocolate let's
try them and pretty wild eh
very
I don't know why didn't he give him the
gluten-free chocolate chip cookies dude
that's what we're saying that's the only
one that we actually liked those are
literally a 10 and I still have one
every other day Sam went and bought like
20 packs you have so many bags they're
so good we had 12 bags oh shoot Jesus Mr
Beast is stressing thought bro was gonna
lie so true
dude but I feel like he just solidified
real Street Credit by not lying them oh
yeah I do think that that chocolate
realistically is more like a five or six
at best yeah
I agree I think at the end there he kind
of he kind of after like Jimmy got up
he's like okay yeah fine and hey it's
okay it's better than Hershey's I like
how it goes it's not crazy it's not
crazy it's pretty good
so good job Keith bro
kept it real
and we love that
um
yes sir
keeping it real
yes yes what else we got here
um
so let's I get move on to the um Darman
controversy
and I've got the Eddie dude from tick
tock
this guy rules
I found this video on Tick Tock
and this is why I was so devastated when
I got banned
[Music]
um
because my feed got all [__] up and I
don't find videos like this you didn't
find them
sorry I gotta defend myself wait hold on
it says it says okay the only reason I
say that because I don't know what I put
in there and whatnot I got I got a
backstory too
here it says
the [__] I thought it said something
where Ethan did you change it right now
baby
change what
the
no okay whatever uh go ahead cam I well
I d i I found this guy and I saw he was
in Burbank and I dm'd him to collab
because I wanted to be a cameo actor in
it oh [__] yeah and he was uh he was
this is the one instance he's been shy
and didn't respond to me he liked my
messages he followed me he likes my
videos but he didn't he didn't want to
reply to me damn and but you'll see when
we watch him big time he's not a shy guy
no Ethan it still says original find
from Ethan Right Here original video
Ethan found okay so that's that's what I
thought okay whatever it doesn't matter
who found it apparently cam found it
I got a big Tick Tock algorithm streak
ride right now I gotta keep my uh yes
so this guy [__] rules it's called
Eddie
love love is
[Music]
put your shirt back on
hey yes I love being at Walmart with my
shirt off I've lost 16 pounds and I look
great so I love being here shopping here
for shoes with my shirt at all
so I'm assuming the way he does this is
he approaches strangers and I he goes yo
I'm gonna need you to ask me
Eddie where's your shirt because he does
this all over America and I will say it
does have a an interestingly compelling
body like it's hairless
it looks good it looks real good good
enough to snack on
[__]
rate it one through ten beat compared to
Beast bar how's it taste
he's on a weight loss Journey right now
so all of his videos are like that it's
really cool here is back in Walmart
I'd love to get him to call and I gotta
know why are you doing in Walmart
put your shirt back on Ed but I love
having my shirt on this is what I do I
break my shirt off when I'm in the
Walmart I love it look I've lost 14
pounds in just 16.
is this so interesting like such an
interesting Niche it's very specific
and the way he get recruits people I
wondered if he has a technique where
he'll be like hey can you do me a favor
and say hey Eddie where's your shirt and
then when they leave
he takes the shirt off and shoots it so
he doesn't freak them out I think he
makes them film it though the people
that no you think he rides solo yeah
because you can see in some of them that
they'll talk back to him like is that is
that good is that good Eddie so that
that is interesting that adds even a new
layer of weird that's why I contact him
too to try and like get his thought
process I'd love to see you in one of
these Kev
what are you doing out here with your
shirt off
put your shirt back on yeah I'm looking
at these classic cars while I have my
shirt off it's freezing out here but I
love to be shirtless with my classic car
Eddie is this incredible or what
is tucking his foot by an interesting
way too yeah he's he's trying to keep
his pants up yeah and I noticed that as
well because that football would have
hung above the pants usually right yeah
yeah well that's where his belly button
is so it's way up there yeah yeah yeah
but it's actually it's actually very
um
it's actually comp very complementary
his body looks interesting yeah and not
in a bad way
does he shave how is he so hairless
true yeah I didn't even note that is he
just naturally hairless or naturally
like that
oh no
I think it's awesome I wish I was a
hairless King
status
uh here he is once again
and the rain Eddie what are you doing
hey Eddie what are you doing here with
your shirt off you got to put your shirt
back on if I love being shirtless here
out here in the beautiful sunshine with
my shirt off it rained but I love being
out here with my shirt off yeah but I
love getting a suntan in Southern
California we're laid back here
that's so dumb yeah it's cloudy outside
oh well
I love that a little walk-off too by the
way this video is 1800 likes so we're
pretty early to the Eddie shirtless
Eddie tray I gotta say that uh a lot of
people on the chat seem to be familiar
they all got very excited when we
brought up Eddie so really yeah it's out
there I mean he has 40 000 followers and
all these videos have like
three digit like you know what I mean
like 300
does he have super viral ones he has 2.2
million likes total if you scroll up so
he definitely has at least a few virals
I think this one is 27 000 views hey
Eddie really proud of you for losing
weight buddy
foreign
that seemed really sincere
I'm really proud of you for losing
weight too bud I'm trying to find one
that has here this one is 25 000 I mean
tone
while he's filming it's awesome that's
fantastic put your shirt back on I know
where that is
this one's iconic what are you doing
without your shirt on
put your shirt back on
okay I hope that worked let's see
I love the
dude this is high level [__]
and Tick Tock makes this kind of stuff
possible this man would never find an
audience
I would not be watching these videos you
didn't Target with your shirt off
oh yes I can look at me now buddy I've
got my shirt off in the Target Look at
me now buddy 85 000 likes so this is his
big viral hit
yes he can I like that a little
combative
yeah he's a little spicier with your
shirt off
oh yes I can look at me now buddy I've
got my shirt off in the target
okay King hey you can't be that's right
Stick it to the Man
I love that oh here's another viral
Eddie thing this was 170 000 likes put a
shirt on you're in the CVS and it's
raining outside
yeah but I like being in a CVS with my
shirt off that's the whole point oh come
on man it's raining now oh she did call
that okay I'll put my shirt back on
thank you thank you make an observation
here how does he get these people to
film things no she was she was into it
that seemed genuine she's either a good
actress or she was actually upset about
that um can you can you pause it when
it's showing Eddie sure
yeah I suspect it is some kind of fetish
thing oh come on but
still great what do you like here Dan
he doesn't have a belly button oh well
his pants are really high that's what we
were discussing yeah he does he just he
pulls him up higher than it looks like
what and he tucks the fupa in that's a
tummy tummy tuck right there yeah
like it's you know how when you're
wearing a dress shirt you tuck the flaps
in yeah but and that he made of that is
just like not adding up to me he's got
low hang he's got a low hand belly
button too he probably lost a lot of
weight it was probably like expanded
before but then it shrunk ended this one
is he's stretched out a little bit this
one has 2.2 million views so this one is
international
being in a Walmart with your shirt off
put your shirt back on it this is a
Walmart
yeah but I love it Walmart with my shirt
off it's way down there or he's like
Kyle XY status yeah exactly he's grown
in a bat yeah he wasn't born exactly
from a human womb yeah
he's tucked it in because you would see
you would see there's some kind of Cliff
there you know what I mean on the bottom
of the fopa
which I would do the same I tuck it in
too if I you know what I mean any chance
I get damn that's a low belly button
though this sounds like someone else
who's filming it listen
Ed what are you doing in a Walmart with
your shirt off
put your shirt back on it this is a
Walmart yeah but I love it that was a
man said go so
this was shot separately yeah but I see
that yeah yeah yeah good catch who's
that person yo chat's saying he was in a
Tim and Eric bit too really yeah
I don't know how they find these people
man because that is just perfection
Craigslist
this one looks like he's just talking
let's see what this one's like here on a
movie set and look what I found
there's the movie said and there's the
what we're doing right now we're getting
the cameras and the lights and the
action
so cute look at that pretty doggy he's
so cute oh here on a movie set he's
wearing a shirt
before he found his calling
yeah let's see what this one is
I can't do that Eddie just mute it cam
somebody said it was in one of the
purple Zone I just I just dropped it you
found it okay
is this is losing weight and looking
good doing it
my man
can I I'm probably gonna get claimed for
this but let's try to look at it real
fast oh this is him he has a talking
part
rules
dealer on a Riverboat named black
Sally's out okay I can't watch any more
than that
they use his real name to Eddie
I think they always do when they get
people like him
it's like it's always their real names
um
the ones that are popular aren't really
like the best ones
I totally agree isn't that interesting
here look at this one
get it back on
what are you doing out here shirt off
this person looks so confused
someone put my shirt off I'd have to
take it off right now
hey put your shirt back on
what are you doing out here shirt off go
but he got so nice and sunny outside I
just thought I'd have to put my shirt
off I'd have to take it off right now
really compelling dialogue I love that
he
he just marches onward If he if he biffs
the line there's just no second takes
it's just raw as it gets yeah and he
left him to go yeah just one oh yo he
found a homie with um
fellow home wow
wow
interesting it's powerful
I mean how do I not see it
the voice was like man I know I'm
getting fat but like if I start wearing
shirts too small to where your gut hangs
out the bottom that I know I know I just
know that that's not a great look yeah
would never let that happen you don't
have to worry yeah hopefully not yeah
man I knew head back from uh Dead shows
man
we said we used to take our shirts off
and watch Grateful Dead yeah he grilled
cheese man
with your shirt on
well I guess if I you will
you really different location entirely
it's just like in an alley now
like what okay well I guess if I you
really want me to take my shirt off okay
I guess I will I love to take my shirt
off thanks for asking oh so you tucked
it yeah He adjusted there thanks for
asking
I do I'm just curious about how this
adjustment look at that sleight of hand
though man thanks for asking I love
having one fast motion
that is right there Eddie what are you
doing out here with your what are you
doing there with half a shirt
yeah
so there you go there's Eddie the man
eating and late weight losses how would
you like to be able to never oh I can't
do that Eddie
sixteen thousand look at that cat one I
want to see the cat video I get people
complimenting me on my look
like ugly in person
ever since I joined Tick Tock I get
people complimenting me on my look you
do a glass ugly in person whatever it's
awesome man I'd love to run into this
guy where's the cat one this one yeah
you had a feeling it was gonna be
waiting let's see collab with him and
Wally P yeah now we're talking can you
keep an eye on Shredder I don't know if
he's trying to get into
better trouble
Ed what are you doing in Walmart with
your shirt off put your shirt back on Ed
but I love having my shirt on this is
what I do I break my shirt off when I'm
in the Walmart I love it look I've lost
14 pounds in just six days what 14
pounds in six days that ain't healthy
he's sponsored by some drink I think
14 pages
yeah the one you skipped he promoted
some kind of a weight loss thing right
who's I mean no offense Eddie but these
videos have like
300 views
I think it's like a referral program
that anyone can do okay okay is my guess
I think he's scared of you Dan I saw
Tick Tock where someone he approached
duetta that Tick Tock he was in and she
said that Eddie says he's doing this for
an improv class
oh my God
like homework for his improv collect
Fight Club this is like a Fight Club
assignment going to a Walmart shirtless
and make people feel he's a meatloaf he
kind of does look like Robert Paul oh
yeah he does totally
I like it
Walmart
we yeah I could totally no way you got
it holy [__] and a drink
oh my God Wham that's a Wham moment
right there oh my God and more fries
anyone else got theirs too oh my God
[Music]
let's get some whams in the chat
holy [__] you guys
that's awesome holy [__] oh my [__]
god dude
I could totally see this guy like
if he falls into the wrong group friend
friend group like blowing up city hall
right oh yeah I can definitely see it
going that way
oh [__]
well Eddie if you're out there
here's Sam just doing avatarship
just Avatar things
we got Wendy's on Pandora
it looks so good
I cannot believe it you need to wear
that again
I think I should like do my errands
after work like this today I think maybe
I have the gym right after work I'm
hoping I get all the blue off yeah you
guys have to show face like this it took
me two days to get the green shirt off
for the gecko and I still finding it in
my ears oh boy yeah I am worried about
that
ah I feel pretty dumb now huh it'll take
a minute
um Cam's Photoshop in the Discord it's
funny
navies
wow I'm not eating this [__]
[__] no that looks kind of good yeah it
looks yummy yeah I'm not eating that
wait is this is this Navi meat
is that the implication here I don't
know everything's blue on that planet
[__] up dude it's actually two two
[__] meat that's even more that's worse
yeah
is there a fast food logo that's blue
uh Sonic no no dot EXE
all right I'm going in for this yeah
they stare clear I feel like the the
blue is not a great color to associate
with food generally I know that uh
if you're on a diet they tell you to eat
off of a red or a yellow plate
um that is real advice I've been given
before wait
a carrots people are saying Culver's is
blue I see we don't have Culvers here I
know that I'm familiar with it though
White Castle Maybe
White Castle is white and blue yeah yes
Ethan is stop you guys are doing it
again
is it good Ethan yeah
you know
the burger is good
the bun is a little something I don't
their buns are a little sweet
like a tub wheat buns
all right thank you Eddie if you're
there call us
we want to meet you do you want me to
reach alcohol yeah okay dude I've tried
I'm in the DMS with him he follows me he
likes all my stuff but he doesn't reply
to me
yeah he likes my he likes my videos he
sends me invites to watch his live
streams but he doesn't reply I don't
know why he's shy in this one instance
did you say like hey we we want you to
call in or something like that or this
is completely I well I gave him a
synopsis of the podcast and everything
and you know he just didn't he just
liked it and didn't think well maybe now
that he's seen us engage with this
contact yeah look at look at me Eddie
I'm a normal guy yeah right yeah just
like you Eddie
we're all normal around here I'll meet
you at any Target Walmart are you
choosing you know you don't have to wear
a shirt
that'd be fun if we all did a video for
him sure
I go go out to meet Eddie I recognize
most of the places in his videos we
could just kind of Snoop around his uh
his hunting ground and see if we run
into it yeah let's talk him and Jimmy
Lee should go around together and take
turns with their bits or their improv I
think Jimmy would turn on Eddie it
wouldn't be good
I'm over Jimmy really
I'm over it
every morning I wake up and he posts
five [__] things it's the first thing
I look at I look at Jimmy Lee every
morning when I wake up and it's hell
just saying he doesn't trust them yeah
that's like a shared experience I also
Jimmy is the first person I see on
Instagram every morning standing anymore
I haven't muted you guys know you could
do it I like it I did do that but I
unmuted
so uh
the Jersey Lawman the jury the Jersey
Lawman yeah his shadow personality I'm
into Europe to your credit he doesn't
have my phone number oh dude he
I almost went off on him like pretty
hardcore uh over the weekend
because I won't get into too much detail
but he must have texted me at least 30
times
why don't you mute him you can block him
well I think it was Friday I don't know
if you told the story Zach how he kept
texting me that he has a problem and
it's serious oh yeah he he wants to do
this restaurant bit and he thinks it's
like the end-all be-all
no not that he how he was texting you
like I got a serious problems I get
serious oh yeah check on him he goes hey
I got a problem my doctor said this my
Proctologist told me you know that type
of job he kept saying I've got problems
Zach yeah that's his new like uh just
like you [__] [__] so he's so
desperate to get your attention now well
that making it seem like there's a
emergency crisis that's what I thought
initially but now this is his new punch
line so I got a problem forgive me for
having a good heart you know and
actually caring about people but I
should have just not answered you know
what Jimmy
what you don't understand about Zach is
that
he makes cashiers days better right
Jimmy makes them worse
you talk with the cashier you ask them
how they're doing
and you wish them a good day Amen
brother
what do you guys think about this AMC
Theater
is going to change how they charge for
tickets based on the quality of the seat
yeah brilliant decision
when
when all of the theaters are in crisis
and uh because everybody's streaming at
home and they all almost went out of
business because of the pandemic let's
just piss off everybody who likes going
to the movie theater why don't you take
a seat right over there I mean in a way
it does kind of make sense though
doesn't it
are they gonna lower the price of the
shitty ones you know they're not it's
gonna go the other way like how much are
they going to charge for the good seats
because I'm not paying like more than
two bucks more
I guess we'll see I I don't know it just
yeah
they want you to bind to their
subscription deal because they don't
have to pay for the good seats or they
get some kind of discount is what I'm
hearing AMC lost nearly 700 million
dollars
in the first three quarters of 2022
that's a lot
they need to
link up with Elon Musk
I think Avatar may have saved the film
industry on its own that's [__] right
all right guys
James Cameron
the greatest ever do it let's talk about
Leo's new girlfriend
so here they are together
or not new girlfriend I mean
because aren't we leaning towards it not
like we already said
wait what are you well is this his
girlfriend or no no it seems like it's a
non-story this girl is 23. oh that one
no no this girl is 19. oh I see yeah
yeah he was just sitting next to her yes
right and people they had a photo
snapped and it got out and people just
assume
because it's Leo it's like oh probably
he's probably dating her and she's 19
years old of this photo it was a like an
album release party or something I think
I read right yeah I have yeah yeah it
was Leo and her name's Eden and they
were at a release party and they were
sitting together I'll be honest he
probably [__] her
like come on he's probably trying yeah
like if Leo's at a private party with a
19 year old model sitting next to him
the math in my opinion checks out
yeah I mean there's enough history with
him that uh
he checks out they were a totally absurd
assumption yeah they were at ebony
Reilly's EP
party
she's with him clearly by her body
language
I mean I'm gonna be reading into that a
little bit no they went together there's
no way okay let's dig let's dig in zoom
in
look at that shirt she's got this face
like she's just kind of waiting for him
she's just kind of on the sideline
interesting he's having a conversation
you know she's feeling a little awkward
because she's out of place she doesn't
know anybody she's there with him you
know what I mean
how does the rest of the story go yeah
yeah I want to know how this ends Two
Chains is there he's playing yeah
it doesn't make sense they go back to a
hot club Hollywood DiCaprio two changes
there oh no DiCaprio was there in his
story just came there yeah keemstar's
there oh my God
my 40th birthday I was in Las Vegas he
dropped her off
I'm good
you guys acting a real fanfic of what
happened yeah
here it is
let me wrap this up then I'll tell you
what happened
obviously they linked up probably on
Instagram
Leo goes
hey obviously you know I just want to
say hi I think you're cute
I'd like to go out for a cup of coffee
sometime with you if you're interested
of course who what what girl would not
agree to that right
you think this was premeditated
this is what happened
is what happened
she of course says yes what girl would
say no
she knows it's wrong she's only 19 but
she knows that every girlfriend of his
probably you know becomes famous too
right it was kind of a good opportunity
and you get to meet Leonardo DiCaprio
who wouldn't want to do that I'd say yes
I'd say yes yeah and so they go out for
coffee they have a nice time
they know each other I see I see
by the time we're at the party we are a
couple we're deep
again I spent the day together he
strategically planned this out so they
go get coffee and he says hey
my friend this famous musician is having
an album release party tonight you want
to come with me of course you're going
to say yes that too right exciting
bombing they start drinking a little bit
he you know
he spends the whole party like he's Leo
like everybody's just louding over him
he this is this man is that biggest
celebrity in the world they're drinking
they're having a good time everyone is
just kind of kissing the ring and she's
she's probably just like
I cannot believe I'm here right now this
is Leonardo DiCaprio the Living God and
that's what that's what he puts out
there right because
that's how people treat him right at
this at this viewing party I'm happy she
didn't get her fake ID taken away what
she didn't get her fake ID taken away at
the door she didn't even get id'd
because she was it's a private party
that's what's so exciting about it oh
she's with Leo obviously yeah it's a
private party and he brings her a drink
yeah they look down
it starts as a champagne that they pass
around on the
the little circles because then it's
like oh you just grab it you hand it to
her then as the night progresses they
start drink a little more he goes hey
I'm gonna go to the bar get a whisk you
want one no he doesn't do that he brings
her back a whiskey he doesn't he doesn't
even ask not a good vibe so they start
drinking they're feeling good they start
making out a little bit okay
so there is a little romance she wasn't
sure she's like I don't know where this
is going I don't know if he's interested
because he's always he plays it aloof he
plays it cool he's Leonardo DiCaprio she
doesn't know how he actually feels then
all of a sudden he starts smacking her a
little bit
and she goes okay so he is into me this
is crazy
invites her back to his place
incredible Penthouse hot floor private
elevator insane
beautiful modern elegant they come out
was the decor like like what is it
modern or is he open space light colors
yeah so it's kind of mirrorless it looks
like the Titanic on the inside no not at
all well that would be opulent yeah
that's what I'm wondering if it's no
it's like Airy it's modern he likes kind
of like that minimal Vibe it's like the
apartment and The Departed goes like the
Gatsby's house
guys were you there I was stop
can we um can you put up the the photo
again Ian can we just take a look at
that this is a lot
come on
it's all there you guys just amazing
enough amount of information that you've
extracted from this Photograph well hold
on I'm not done I don't even know if
they smashed or not I'm not done
I'm waiting
they come out of the elevator stunning
modern she's never been in a place this
nice top Penthouse probably and
Santa Monica overlooking the beach or
you know Beverly Hills or one of those
tall skyrises
and she's just stunned this is like
she feels like she's in a movie
so he pours some like really nice
champagne they start drinking they start
talking a little bit he moves in closer
they start making out
they both knew where this was going
coming they start making out they do
some heavy Pat petting
things are hitting up then Leo says
excuse me for a minute
walks comes back to the bathroom here
comes the twist
[Music]
he says join me in the bed would you
want to join me in the bedroom they
start de-clothing themselves they start
feeling and touching going around to
Third Base which I believe is
probably oral sex
feelings yeah right so they're on
they're on they're on second base okay
just second
[Music]
sex she puts his hand down his pants
because she's she's like ready to go
jacket off and what's interesting is
that he's limp
totally lit right oh he's got that
whiskey dick
well I think the problem actually goes
even deeper than the whiskey I think Leo
has an issue he's been nothing excites
him he he cannot get hard he went to the
bathroom and ate like you know five
Viagra something yeah and he thinks if I
can get this 19 year old model this
beautiful
goddess
then I'm going to be able to get it hard
and he he comes back and he despite how
much Viagra he gets he cannot get hard
and it's and he's thinking his heart is
pounding because now he's embarrassed
and he's thinking not again and now
she's like she's thinking am I not good
enough am I not hot enough she doesn't
know that he has this problem so she's
she's trying to jerk off this little
dick you know how awkward that is I'm
terrible it's just not moving at all man
and uh I'll tell you what she even she's
like okay maybe if I go down on him
uh something will happen so she starts
going down
socks and I know this is graphic but
it's not moving
also I'll say that Leo he doesn't he
doesn't manscape he doesn't care because
he's from Leonardo DiCaprio is
overground he's got record the Titanic
at the bottom of the Atlantic this man
has pubes for days so it's not that nice
of a situation for her but she does it
anyway because it's awkward and she
feels bad and she's feeling insecure
[Music]
mm-hmm so she goes down he can't get it
up she says she tries and tries nothing
happens
and she says there's something wrong
and he says no there's nothing wrong
she's been a long night
she you know he feels bad she feels bad
he's just trying to smooth it over
obviously this isn't the first time it's
happened to him
he says it's not you it's just maybe
it's the alcohol he blames the alcohol
and he goes well you know what
it's been a long night I'm getting kind
of tired maybe you want if you want to
head out we can talk later
she heads home
never hears from him again
wow
and the truth is I think what Leo's
standard is
is that if a girl can get him hard
either
probably by putting a finger and getting
his prostate going or something like
that
but there's something so so the girl
didn't get him hard and it's not her
fault but she goes home and they never
talk again and he blocks her on
Instagram well listen I didn't really
think there was any validity to this
story I thought you were digging way too
deep into a single photograph
but it's just been brought to light that
that photograph is actually cropped
in the original
well
[__] that was right after I got
out of the IHOP or whatever yep Denny's
what was it yeah you were just farting
up a storm in Denny's a few minutes
before and you're like I got this invite
to this uh release party I'll go I
followed you're like I'm gonna say [__]
Leo and follow him home yeah see what
he's up to right did you guys know that
that what I just said is basically 100
true yeah don't don't tell me you
couldn't see it all happening
I'd say it's just as possible it's
nothing happening it's happening which
is saying something let's do a poll
maybe they just happen to be sitting
next to each other I mean it's like the
line no no that's impossible I think the
bathroom line probably
Dan are you that are you that naive bro
I'm not it's I'm not listen I'm not
totally discrediting your version of
these events clearly you were there you
have more insight into the situation
than me I'm just offering an alternative
explanation
right the way she's turned towards him
and flicking her hair if they're
together I'm sorry
you guys are just way off base
I agree with you Ethan thank you Zach
somebody who understands me
I will say she is like leaning into him
more than together you would a stranger
I I will say that yeah they went there
together dude
the hair flicking is is a sign of like
comfortability she's oh yeah
everyone's goofing on him on Twitter
though can you do a poll if people think
that what I said is accurate or no
I I mean I can sure oh
is Ethan's
version of events accurate I don't think
Leo can get it up no
let's see what he thinks
I think he thinks by dating these young
models to
somehow gonna help him get hard
eighty percent yes Dan eat it
[Laughter]
I was going down a little bit but not a
lot
yeah it looks like um it looks like the
audience is on board with your version
of events and again I I mean you were
there
I'm not trying to Discount that so
you clearly have more insight into this
situation than any of us this is a bad
poll however so oh is it the uh what do
you think it's a bad poll
well what's the problem they all are
so I see good pull
all right that's pull here's people
goofing on them on Twitter
good night especially to Leo who is now
dating the 19 year old goddess of Youth
who what's her name can I see a
different picture of her is she a famous
model
um Eden Palani because I kind of want to
get it like see how how young does she
look
but she's she's a model I'm assuming
so let me ask you a serious question
what are the chances that of young
famous model just happens to be sitting
next to Leo that's his type that's you
know I mean that's like his type
We Are Young we are old I mean I know he
dates young women has he ever dated a 19
year old has it ever been that young
I don't know
young 20s for sure people thought he was
going to mature and date older hell no
he's going though
the women get younger
oh she's Israeli
there it is I mean it's hard it's kind
of hard to tell her age in these like
massive crazy photoshops I bet if you
saw her in person she'd look like a
child
I know Ethan's Jewish and you're Jewish
but the playing the Hava Nagila as soon
as we mentioned that anyone is Jewish it
feels a little anti-semitic I'll have to
point that out well that's Jewish how I
know I gotta star David around my neck I
get it anti-semitic I I'm not saying
that you're anti-semiticism I'm saying
it feels anti-semitic it's like Ava
Nagila every time a Jewish person okay
let me help with an analogy maybe okay
if every time a Hispanic person comes on
you play like Mariachi yeah yeah
like even if you were Mexican wouldn't
that feel oh well I feel look I feel
like this is this is like you know I
like it though it's a Jewish podcast
like I don't know maybe and look at it
I'm not accusing you of being
anti-semite I'm just pointing out I'm
embracing it's a Jewish
podcasting don't worry about it podcast
that's like when they said Seinfeld's a
Jewish show
it is okay but the only person you do to
please is me and I like it okay then
that's all that matters all right fair
enough I've set my piece every time
someone's uh Arrow by the way said can
you play some like play uh yeah can I
make a really offensive joke no no no
you can't you tell me after the show I'd
love to hear it yeah
if you have to type it it's it's already
a no let me type it and then you can say
here we go
this is progress honestly no yeah
it's a good joke
[Music]
absolutely not I know
I see I I wouldn't be comfortable doing
that of course
you can say it if you want yeah
but I want to correct you and say that's
not actually a thing
it's not like Seinfeld
whatever it is
hard to find I don't think it became
harder to find
the Mariachi ones are good enough there
was a plenty good analogy it was well
he's the one that started it he said
when an Arab comes on as an Arab I was
okay but I wouldn't be comfortable with
that because it wouldn't be my place to
do that I feel as a Jewish Jewish person
I feel like there it is you know
there it is
Dan
podcast Dan he has dated
you guys wouldn't get it it's a Jew
thing you wouldn't get it Dan you're
Jewish embrace it I'm Jewish I'm like
I'm Jewish the way George Santos is
Jewish
guys
let's not do an avatar here
and what does that mean
you know create an epic piece of content
that is beloved he dated a 20 year old
twice recently 2018 and 2012 that's not
recent but yeah he dated a 20 21 and 22
year old recently so 19 is not out of
the question for him
I'm 21. [__] you
so actually I was gonna defend him but
after seeing these he's 100 I don't know
if they're dating but he definitely took
her out on this day
he has been linked recently to a 23 year
old model named uh Victoria it hasn't
been announced that they broke up but
she was not present at the party I would
date like the absolute youngest
yeah
so she's anyway back to the Tweet good
night especially to Leonardo DiCaprio
who's now dating the 19 year old goddess
of Youth he now has a full sixth year of
dating her before she gets too old love
that for him true love at its finest
fun fact she was negative seven years
old when Titanic came out inspiring
his face
Dane Cook I'm dating a 23 year old
Leonardo DiCaprio hold my beer Leonardo
DiCaprio's girlfriend I can't
that's good
[Music]
so Leonardo DiCaprio's nearly 50 and
dating somebody who went to prom on Zoom
wow these people are funny
yeah there's some good ones that's why
even though all jokes aside it does
appear to be at least publicly debunked
that they were together what do you mean
publicly debunked both parties denied it
of course they did
I don't be born yesterday
the public nudity calls are interesting
people with the same age Gap as Leonardo
DiCaprio that's [__] up bro that's
crazy no million her stepdad
and The Last of Us oh [__] that does not
that's not good at all no
Leonardo DiCaprio fighting climate
change to leave a better planet for his
girlfriends
love that these people are [__] on
fire Leonardo DiCaprio's girlfriend is
so young her High School experience was
interrupted by cover 19. it's kind of
similar not as funny honestly as the
zoom it's not way more likes which is
unfortunate yeah
this one was we already read so
yeah he's getting skewered
and rightfully so
I wish you just stopped bro
see I saw an article that said he was
dating a 29 year old model and I was
like wow he broke the curse
but
actually it's a 10 years difference
so there it is Leonardo DiCaprio ladies
and gentlemen he does not care at all
yes yes
it says how long we've been going there
Dano we've been going three hours so
well that about cues me up so remember
guys there is no leftovers tomorrow
Hassan has a obligation to do something
for twitch
I don't you know but yeah he won't be
here so we're not gonna have an episode
tomorrow
but we will have a banger episode on
Friday
with
who's coming on Friday Ian and Denise oh
yeah iananisa Banger Banger alert Banger
should we dress up like this again you
think what do you think I think this is
the new you yeah I think you need to do
it everyday I think you the person you
dress up as is Dan I've been feeling
myself today you know maybe you've
finally found your true self all these
years you've been wearing the mask you
just took it off
you can't keep playing with your hair I
have noticed that
you keep going like it's constantly
falling into my face which is not a
problem as you probably can surmise that
I deal with very often can I say
something
I feel absolutely dog [__] after eating
that channel
so [__] gross and regretful
anyone else yeah I'm not feeling too hot
either you feeling that AB or no yeah I
feel like [__] yeah
God damn that shit's nasty it wasn't
that good The Burger wasn't that good I
like that it was Square though I don't
know where all the hype came from with
Wendy's it's Wendy's I usually like it
but low tier just saying I remember it
being really good it was mid it was mid
I'm just gonna be real it was mid
fast food though what do you want it's
like Mr B's chocolate
would you rather eat a piece of dog [__]
off the ground or some Wendy's I would
no I would pick Wendy's every time man
100 of the damn ringing endorsement
foreign
those Mr Beast Burgers weren't far off
from dog [__] though I will say that it
was that bad it was yeah the chicken
burger was home don't you remember oh
they were like under they were like pink
and like uncooked chicken and yeah it
was so catastrophe yeah right an edible
garbage it was the worst Food experience
I've ever had off ordering garbage
garbage garbage stick to the cookies
dude that's I've seen the good amount of
advertising for the cookies oh no the
DAR man [__] I wanted to talk about
Darman
I have till 4 30 if I want to get home
in a normal time so we can just hit it
real quick right now we have to spend it
why'd you tell me Darman like Star man
because it just made me think of the
song star man duh
so Darman I don't watch his videos
I know that there apparently some people
like them I don't know who they're like
painfully corny
like uh obvious lessons I don't know who
this [__] is helping
am I right yeah they're always 17
million he's huge I mean the one
everybody's throwing examples of is
there was one that was like a boss was
terrible to his employee and look what
happened and it's always like
you know somebody being mean or bullying
somebody and then they get taught him
a lesson but it's always you know
they always come together in the end and
they realize that they were wrong about
what they were doing and but he's he
presents himself like the moral compass
of the whole [__] world right he's
like inspirational everything is
inspirational life lesson I don't know
who's dude these get so many views and I
just don't [__] get it at all
at all it has to be Facebook
but these are views on YouTube yeah on
Facebook but yeah I think they come over
after seeing them on Facebook
dude these have these all have like
three million four million views
and it reminds me of like mental you
remember Mentos commercials from like
the early 2000s yeah
his videos are that
those are Snappers these are like
they're always gonna be long too this is
part of the problem with these remember
when Trisha was doing like weird Darman
videos per minute I sure do that was
[__] wild dude
yeah it really it it is it just kids
watching it because it doesn't seem
geared towards kids is the weird thing
but like what kid was the level of like
lesson that's being taught is like what
you would show to like elementary school
kids to like teach them something dude I
would not want to watch this I it's like
it's so boring yeah and preachy be quiet
[Music]
oh whoops Jamie Preston I saw that
you're on big trouble young man
not sure what the lesson was there
[Music]
missed the lesson on that one eh maybe
that was just a teaser for the next
Edition perhaps
boy rejected in front of school anyway
uh you guys know what Darman is now I'll
preface this by saying my brother-in-law
does um
he's a high school teacher and he does
one-on-one like special
I don't know what it is but he does
one-on-one with with students it's some
kind of special program and he was
telling me like a month ago
that one of his kids works for Darman
and he was shocked
by when what this kid told him about his
working conditions this was a month ago
firsthand and I was like wow that sounds
crazy he was the kid said that like um
he has to drive super far he pays for
his own transportation he pays a minimum
wage
there's no like support for him being
like an underage he's under 18.
foreign
he only does it because he thinks it's
like an opportunity but he basically
almost loses money going there and
coming back paying for his
transportation
wait it's for English it's for people to
learn English
saw a few people in the chat saying that
uh that's why I like the dialogue is so
like slow and kind of like simplistic or
whatever I kind of believe that I don't
know if that was the original intent but
I could definitely see that being used
for that you know
I would love to see the geographical
breakdown then
yeah but yeah the kid was the kid my
brother-in-law was like shocked that
this huge YouTuber was just paying
and and this was a child this this kid
was under 18 he was in high school
and um
it sounded really bad right
and uh well it comes out that
apparently a lot of his employees have
been feeling the same way according to
actors Darman hasn't been paying them
enough money even to pay rent and treats
them with disrespect
at this actor Colin Borden put out a
tick tock wow calling out what the heck
star man
wow this got a lot of views it has 500
000 likes heck is going on hey Colony
Borden here uh I don't normally like to
uh do serious things
anywhere
um but especially here on social media
because I think it's a rather frivolous
sort of thing and as an actor a writer
director I just think of myself as an
Entertainer and I like to do entertain
things even if that's me pretending to
think that I'm gonna die because I ate
unwashed pepper
get on with it bro
anyways
what you got to say
but now I am going to talk about
something a little serious because uh
you know if you've been following my
page or in other people's pages from the
show that I'm on you probably know that
some stuff is going down so I want to
give a little bit of an explanation
about it essentially as an actor at
Darman Studios I am just a contract
player I have no employment there I am
just sort of called every now and then
as are all the other actors and it just
is not sustainable
um and there are a lot of issues at hand
here but uh one of the main issues is
that not a single actor that works at
Diamond Studios can afford rent this is
a show that has millions of views across
multiple social media platforms
um videos are
chat edited posted repackaged as new
videos repost in other places over and
over and over and over and over again
Wrecking in millions of views ad Revenue
all this sort of stuff the studio has
continued to expand for some time my
entire tenure there when I first started
we shot everything as I've told you guys
on lives and things like that we shot
everything in an apartment building
downtown in an apartment not even the
building occasionally we would go to the
garage of that building but it was
really just all in one apartment and now
there are three sound stages in Burbank
but things haven't really gotten better
for us and again I don't want to go into
specifics because it's a kind of a big
thing and it's really just because
specific you better start because you
should be aware three minutes left why
we are protesting why we are out there
it won't let me Zoom okay there
right now we've been talking to a lot of
actors
um
it's the same everybody feels the same
across the board the trouble is uh
there's a culture at the studio of if
you talk you're out so we decided to
come together as a group and talk
collectively with our boss darmian
we sent a letter to him uh a hard copy
and an email the email was cc to the
head of production as well so that we
made sure that Dar got it but it was
addressed to darn
um it was delivered to DAR that letter
was forwarded to the HR department which
we are not employees of dark man Studios
we are contract players uh so exactly
what we have to do with HR we're not
entirely sure but it was forwarded over
I think I know what this name is what
I think I think I know what this means
cheers
no no no I mean that's that's fine too
but but Dan is absolutely correct maybe
you could just like overlay this somehow
this [__] is boring as [__]
bro can I get some kinetics in oh cool
there's a guy chasing him I didn't know
about that so I'm thinking Ian maybe you
could just like meeting real quickly put
this on the inside our issues yeah I'll
play a meeting was pushed several times
changed on us I got you guys uh when we
finally got that's so cool when did they
add the security guard reiterated that
we wanted it to be with DAR was not
there was that always though yeah
if you messed up then he comes closer I
haven't played Subway Surface
everybody's on the same page but our
meeting is with our boss the person who
signs our contracts
darmian thank you very much please get
back to us
um with a time for the next meeting by
next Tuesday just a time for the meeting
not necessarily the next meeting can you
play the chestnut song as well Zach
said this in person we reiterated it a
few minutes I can watch uh we checked
back in uh following a couple days now
this is good again
every lobe of my brain this is our boss
[Music]
whether it's connected or not he's still
talking because no one's talking to us
[Music]
and that's just not acceptable
I wonder how do they get it so
[Music]
incredibly proud that's good that's
incredible community over here oh Beast
sounds that's chilling me out
[Music]
because in my obituary whether I go
tomorrow or they're still talking did he
say a [__] or whatever I don't know I
can't hear I've loved my time at Tarman
and it has so much that has to do with
people oh that sand is so good this
little video right now so thank you to
you
um thank you for being a
[Music]
subscribe my brown noise
foreign
[Music]
thank you very much
anyway you're welcome bud
what thank you for sharing your story
[Laughter]
[Applause]
workers of the World Unite but can I so
I watched that whole video last night
okay would you like me to give uh sure I
just watched go ahead
he's been working on these Darman videos
for years it started out as a small
Studio over time it's become massively
successful against like billions of
views all the time and they've expanded
into a giant facility over in Burbank
they have three sound stages he said and
uh over the course of their massive
success they have not raised what they
pay the actors at all in that entire
time and so the actors approached him to
ask uh collectively if they could get a
raise because they are not being paid a
living wage
they at first gave them a meeting but
Darman refused to attend they asked for
another meeting and said we're not going
to talk with anybody unless he's here
they said okay sure we'll schedule that
and then instead they were informed
their services well that that meeting is
not going to happen that's scummy dude
Darman it's just like dude you make
inspirational videos don't be a scumbag
yeah
yeah that's the long the pro the real
issue here
is the same it's like employment on
YouTube
actors it's not regulated there's an
actor's guild there's a there's a union
for this that that regulates because
it's so easy to exploit these workers
and it sounds like that's exactly what
he's doing and you know
it really just underlies a need for some
kind of Regulation or unions for
Child Actors and actors like and
darman's [__] I guess it should be
said sag uh does have a digital contract
for like for content on YouTube and
stuff but I I think it's barely ever
used
um
uh but for something on the scale of
what they're doing where again
um because they were all outside
protesting I saw where it is I mean it's
right in the heart of Burbank giant
facility here like bigger bigger
building than we have is the problem
with really nice sound stages and
everything it's clearly it's a high
level production they're running over oh
yeah it looked super high yeah quality
um but there's a lot of people there
actually yeah so I think they're they're
well within their right too
um
he said what he was being paid but again
he didn't mention it no my
brother-in-law he lives in Camarillo so
this kid drives all the way to LA
that's always and he pays him like uh
less than 100 bucks for a day's rate
yeah that's outrageous
it's outrageous
so
it's just great it's like needlessly
greedy because they do make so much
money
I mean they'd have to [__] we pay people
like a way more than that just for like
for little gags like when we bring in
like big players on the podcast and
stuff we pay significantly more than
that
I wouldn't even pay someone 100 bucks
even for a gag it's almost like
Consulting it's not worth it less than
minimum wage I mean usually I guess it
just depends on how long of a day it is
but it's not
it's not at all unusual for an actor to
need to be on set for 10 12 hours that's
it that was the other part he did super
long days it was 10 12 hours which is
standard and he would pay him a hundred
dollars yeah that's not standard that
part's not standard yeah having
extremely long shooting days is very
very common in Hollywood but um but
paying them that little is that's
outrageous and apparently also was on
like weekdays so the kid was missing
school because he thought it was this
great opportunity
and um
yeah it sounds like he was totally fine
yeah they need to Pony up that's absurd
and yeah I mean we know
uh we've we don't know firsthand but we
heard from other people that the uh the
money on Facebook compared to YouTube
look up his page let's see what's he
doing yeah I'm pretty sure he's
huge on Facebook did we mention today
yet that I donated ten thousand and one
dollars no also I had a question have
you ever smoked crack cocaine before yes
and also I've I've both smoked crack
cocaine cracker hi my name's Ethan Klein
I smoked crack one time
also I donated ten thousand and one
dollars yesterday to a relief fund for
the horrible earthquakes that affected
all of our
brothers and sisters out there in the
Middle East
wishing them all the best this is Ethan
smoked crack one time climb
thanks for watching Everybody Darman has
29 million followers on Facebook so can
you pull can you pull up some like the
views on that kind of stuff yeah let me
um
see
I mean they're posting so much so like
there's there's a bunch of videos posted
just within the last few yeah but let me
go back a couple days and see but yeah
that when like partner channels like him
there I'm sure he's making like crazy
money yeah
um does Facebook not show you views you
got to click on the he has I'm looking
at his recent five hours ago he posted
hot girls use these nice guys live to
regret it 16.9 million views holy from
how many hours ago five
oh darmen can afford to pay more than
100. you're such a greedy pieces of [__]
that's insane
like holy [__] like you could pay them
250 and that's still on the low end for
a full day's work that's but like
yeah like all of the videos that he's
posted with in the last days like let me
see what scale is for the digital
contract like basically the the lowest
you're allowed to pay how much do we pay
people for a day rate usually when they
just come in and [__] around it's like
well I'm gonna look it up right now like
there there's there's
official rulings on this from the actors
Union dude this guy's a piece of [__]
scale digital con 16 million views what
was the title of it
that one was hot girls use these nice
guys live to regret it dude he's doing
incel [__]
yeah he's doing the red pill content on
Facebook sounds like it well
that's what makes the money right how
does he have a million views on this one
he uploaded an hour ago in 15 comments
that's crazy oh that is sus maybe the
comment section is lost something I'm
sorry oh 11 million views wait he's
probably getting [__] on on comments
right now so he's probably just locked
it down eh
no they're still open
this is a hell of a title poor girl
adopted by billionaires what happens
next is shocking
okay
What hap what social what happens it's
shocking
sounds bad
yeah so this is pretty interesting
Darman
do you actually here let me go back and
listen to this guy's story kind of a big
thing and it's really just between it
this is pretty compelling
you probably know that some stuff is
going down so I want to give a little
bit I didn't give him a fair Shake
because I want to listen this time for
real at darmian Studios I am just a
contract player I have no employment
there I am just sort of called every now
and then as our all the other actors
right and it just is not sustainable
um and there are a lot of issues at hand
here but uh one of the main issues is
that not a single actor that works at
Diamond Studios can afford rent this is
a show that has millions of views across
multiple social media platforms
um videos are shot edited posted
repackaged his new videos and posted in
other places over and over and over and
over and over again okay
[Music]
the studio has continued to expand for
some time my entire tenure there when I
first started we shot everything as I've
told you guys on lives and things like
that we shot everything in an apartment
building downtown from an apartment not
even a building occasionally we would go
to the garage
uh no sorry I was looking up the uh the
SAG rates
I need your help it's really just all in
one oh do you need uh I know what you
need and now there are three sound
stages okay hold on stop stop everybody
stop okay let me try this joke again
okay you know what I didn't give this
guy a fair Shake uh I feel like let's go
back and and give it a good watch and
hear what he has to say no actor that
works at Diamond Studios can afford rap
this is a show that has millions of
views across multiple social media
platforms
um videos are
chat edited posted repackaged as new
videos reposting other places
the studio has continued to expand for
some time my entire tenure there when I
first started we shot everything as I've
told you guys on lives and things like
that shot everything in an apartment
building downtown an apartment not even
in the building right occasionally we
would go to the garage of that building
but it was really just all in one
apartment and now there are three sound
sages
kind of a big thing and it's really just
between us but I think that people
should be aware of let's get a new job
we are protesting why we are out there
right now we've been talking to a lot of
actors
um it's the same everybody feels the
same across the board the trouble is uh
we were never in a relation
[Music]
what we have to do
really short but it was forwarded over
there we were contacted said we could
have a meeting to discuss our issues
that meeting was pushed several times
changed on us okay
I finally got to the meeting
we had reiterated
[Music]
huh
I'm gonna put on yeah I'm gonna play his
podcast with Jason
all right
people are bailing on the stream pretty
quickly here
I'm finally following what he's saying
foreign
thank you
[Applause]